Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Ich hatte die Möglichkeit, über all die Zeit ein wahnsinnig privilegiertes Leben zu führen. Das habe ich mir damit ermöglicht. Und bei allem Ehrgeiz und bei allem Streben nach mehr sollte man unterm Strich dann aber auch seine Situation vernünftig, sinnvoll und vor allem auch in einem größeren Kontext einordnen können. Und da habe ich schon verdammt viel Glück gehabt.
Da hat er verdammt viel Glück gehabt. Und wir haben verdammt viel Glück, dass wir die Fortsetzung dieses Tribünengesprächs, das ihr da eben in einem kurzen Ausschnitt gehört habt, aufnehmen können. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Tribünengespräch Nummer 28 mit Ralph Gunesch. Hallo Ralph. Genau, Frank ist nämlich auch wieder mit dabei. Servus Frank. Ja, schön, dass du mal wieder Zeit für uns hast. Das Tribünengespräch damals zu deiner Karriere. Es ist leicht eskaliert, zeitlich gesehen fünf Stunden und 38 Minuten. Ich glaube, ganz knapp an der Taktikfolge dran. Also zweitlängstes Tribünengespräch aller Zeiten immer noch.
Ich finde, das ist das Gegenteil von naiv. Aber die Frage ist ja auch so ein bisschen jetzt auch mal weggegangen von deinen Spielern. Glaubst du, dass so etwas weit verbreitet ist? Also es gibt Gerüchte, dass ein Nationalspieler ins WM-Trainingslager seine Wasserpfeife mitgenommen hätte. Zum Beispiel. Wo ich tatsächlich dann erstaunt bin.
Ich wäre auch überrascht, wenn ich bei einer WM sowas auf dem Zimmer sehen würde.
Wenn das so alles stimmt. Ich habe das logischerweise nicht gesehen und da habe ich auch keine zwei Quellen jetzt zugehört. Aber glaubst du, dass ja auch unter dem... Ich will das gar nicht jetzt nur verteufeln, sondern in diesem unglaublichen Druck unter dem Profi-Fußballer stehen. Ja, in allen liegen. Vielleicht sogar in den unteren liegen. Manchmal mehr als in den oberen liegen, weil es da auch schneller um Existenzen und so weiter geht. Weil da nicht das ganz große Geld verdient wird. Da braucht jeder Dinge, um diesen Druck auch mal abzulassen. Und glaubst du, da sind dann auch eben solche Dinge vielleicht noch weiterverbreitet, als man denkt? Und vielleicht rutscht man da auch schneller in so eine Abhängigkeit dann auch rein?
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Formulierung, als man so denkt, wirklich die richtige ist. Ich weiß nicht, was der bundesdeutsche Schnitt denkt, wie viele Fußballer in irgendeiner Form Wasser pfeifen oder Zigarren oder Zigaretten oder Schnupftabak zur Entspannung brauchen. Das weiß ich nicht. Ja, Spieler suchen sich oder nicht nur Spieler, Menschen suchen sich Dinge, bei denen sie abschalten und entspannen können. Die einen spielen Playstation, die anderen lesen guten Krimi, der nächste löst Puzzle, der übernächste liest wissenschaftliche Abhandlungen.
Dass du Fortnite immer noch nicht genannt hast, ist natürlich ein Witz. Die spielen alle Fortnite.
Naja, ich bin kein Fortnite-Spieler. Hab ich nicht gesagt Playstation? Hab ich nicht gesagt? Playstation, Xbox, spielen mit der Wii, spielen Pokern, machen dies, machen das. Das gibt es alles. Das eine mehr, das andere weniger. Aber ich habe jetzt auch keinen Prozentsatz für dich. Aber das gibt es natürlich alles. Ich meine, es sind halt auch keine Mönche, die wirklich hinter verschlossenen Türen leben und nur ihr Gebetsbuch haben und nur den Glauben an was auch immer in diesem Kloster gelehrt wird, sondern wirklich Menschen mit all den Vor- und Nachteilen, die Menschsein mit sich bringt. Übrigens, das wird auch häufig vergessen.
Ja, es ist ja auch tatsächlich immer ein schmaler Grad, auch in der journalistischen Betrachtung. Du bewertest eine sportliche Leistung, aber diese sportliche Leistung hat keine Maschine erbracht und auch niemand, von dem man erwarten kann, dass er immer zu 100 Prozent da ist. Genauso wie man als Journalist schlechte Tage hat. So ist das auch den Profisportlern zugestanden.
Aber das wiederum, damit es nicht heißt, ich will jetzt hier nur Spieler verteidigen. Natürlich hast du als Fußballer, als Hochleistungssportler, wenn wir mal weggehen nur vom Fußball, auch eine gewisse Verantwortung dir gegenüber, deinem Körper gegenüber, damit du diese körperlichen Höchstleistungen halt auch nicht nur einmal, sondern eine ganze Saison über oder über einen gewissen Zeitraum abrufen kannst, wo wir wieder bei der Thema Aufklärung wären. Was hat einen positiven, was hat einen negativen Effekt? Natürlich kann ich eine Woche auch überleben, wenn ich nur vier Stunden die Nacht schlafe. Als junger Papa, du weißt wovon ich spreche. Ja, aber du hast es trotzdem irgendwie geschafft.
Klar.
Aber ich glaube, langfristig, wenn ich dich jetzt noch dazu gebracht hätte, dass du jede Woche körperliche Höchstleistung bringst, noch im Sport oder so, wäre das nach einem gewissen Zeitraum auch schwierig geworden. So, und jetzt ist Vatersein, Muttersein sicherlich, nicht nur sicherlich, das ist was ganz, ganz Schönes, habe ich zumindest gehört, ich bin es noch nicht, aber was ganz Tolles und das gibt dir auch unheimlich viel Kraft und Energie. Aber andere Dinge, über die wir zum Beispiel eben gesprochen, die rauben dir halt nur Energie. Und wie viel lasse ich jetzt davon zu? Deswegen mein Ansatz der Aufklärung, nicht der Verbote.
Das ist so ein Themenkomplex, der schließt da noch so ein bisschen dran an. Da hat Highlord Alarak eine Frage gestellt, und zwar in Bezug auf das Spiegelinterview mit Martesacker über Druck im Fußball. Ich finde, wir sind jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen in diesem Themenkomplex drin. Wie glaubst du, hat sich der Druck im Fußball verändert? Hat er zugenommen? Er fragt, denkst du, es ändert sich etwas an diesen Zuständen? Kann beispielsweise ein Abstiegskampf einen so großen Druck verursachen, dass man in eine Negativspirale eintaucht? Du hast auch im Tribünengespräch damals gesagt, dass du dich über den Klassenhalt mit Ingolstadt damals gar nicht freuen konntest, weil einfach dieser ganze Druck so groß war, dass du eigentlich nur noch emotional leer warst. Wie siehst du diesen ganzen Themenkomplex?
Ich fand Pärs Interview großartig. Kurz danach hat auch Robert Bauer im Kilkarn ein Interview in die Richtung gegeben. Ich hab ja auch bei Bundesliga auch mein Statement zu dem Thema abgegeben. Hab Pär auch gesagt, dass ich das großartig fand, was er da gesagt hat. Geändert hat sich nichts, Punkt. In der Wahrnehmung hat sich nichts verändert. In der Art und Weise hat sich nichts verändert. Das große Problem ist aber auch, was möchtest du... Fangen wir mal auf der aktiven Seite an. Was möchtest du ändern?
Auf der aktiven Seite meinst du jetzt von Spielertränern.
Spielerträner, was möchtest du ändern?
Ich weiß es nicht. Er hat ja vor allem dann auch gesagt in diesem Artikel, dass er seine Erfahrungen mit in den Jugendbereich mitnehmen möchte. Ich glaube, im Profi-Fußball wirst du dich ja diesen Druck... Du kannst ihm dir ja nicht entziehen.
Ja gut, du kannst die Champions League auflösen, du kannst die Europa League auflösen und sagen, wir spielen jetzt alle nur noch...
Das ist Quatsch, es wird immer ein Wettbewerb sein. Aber er hat ja zum Beispiel gesagt, er möchte diese Erfahrung mitnehmen und in seiner Tätigkeit verwenden, die er dann im Nachwuchsbereich bei Arsenal macht.
Das meine ich ja, den Druck kannst du nicht wegnehmen. Weil dann müssten wir den Wettbewerb auflösen und müssten nur noch zum Spaß spielen. Also wirklich nur noch zum Spaß und völlig ergebnisunabhängig. Das, was er sich vorgenommen hat oder was er jetzt auch umsetzt, genau dasselbe versuche ich auch. Plus, das finde ich, da muss ich meine Antwort von eben minimal korrigieren, hat sich schon ein Stück weit verändert. Vereine werden sich der Verantwortung bewusster. Und immer mehr Vereine haben mittlerweile tatsächlich auch Sportpsychologen im NLZ. Also wir haben jetzt auch eine Sportpsychologin bei uns im NLZ, die auch regelmäßig mit Mannschaften, Gruppen und Einzelspielern spricht. Weil das natürlich auch ganz, ganz sensible Altersstrukturen in so einem NLZ sind. Wir sprechen hier von Jungs zwischen, bzw. auch Mädels. Also ich glaube, die 10-Jährigen musst du noch nicht zwingend so häufig zu ihr schicken. Aber dann so U16 geht es halt los bis U19. Das ist dann so die Übergangszeit, weil dann kommt schon auch Druck. Das ist Jugendleistungsfußball. Also wir spielen nicht nur, um Spaß zu haben. Wir wollen auch zum Beispiel die Klasse halten, um dem nächsten Jahrgang auch wieder eine bestmögliche Ausbildung ermöglichen zu können und und und. Das ist auch eine Form von Druck. Und ja, sensibles Alter. Die sind mitten in der Pubertät. Es kommen ganz viele neue Eindrücke. Was mache ich? Wie geht es im Fußball weiter? Die U19, die schreiben jetzt Abitur. Also die haben jetzt die Abiturphase. Wie geht es nach der Schule weiter? Studiere ich? Erste Freundin, erster Freund. All diese Dinge, die wir auch alle durchgemacht haben, prasseln dann auf einmal auf Jungs und Mädels ein, die jetzt aber auch auf fußballerischer Ebene neuen Druck verspüren und vielleicht noch nicht wissen, wie sie damit umgehen sollen. Und das ist der Ansatz auch von Peer. Dem folgen halt, nicht weil sie das Interview gelesen haben, sondern weil sie sich einfach auch dieser Verantwortung mittlerweile bewusst geworden sind, weil sich auch der Jugendfußball professionellisiert hat, folgen die Vereine, in denen sie jetzt Sportpsychologen und Sportpsychologinnen oder deren Expertise in Anspruch nehmen und die Jungs und Mädels damit arbeiten lassen. Und das finde ich gut. Weil es ist vorbereitend. Es ist vorbereitend auf das, was hoffentlich vielleicht für den ein oder anderen dann auch in größerem Maße oder was den ein oder anderen dann erwartet.
Das heißt, der Ansatz muss sein, dadurch, dass wir den Druck im Profibereich ja sowieso, der wird immer da sein und der wird auch nicht geringer werden. Deswegen müssen wir quasi die jungen Menschen schon Techniken an die Hand geben oder mit dem Thema auch einfach vertraut machen, dass sie mit diesem Druck umgehen können, ohne dass der Druck zu groß, zu dominierend wird.
Ja, und das ist gar nicht so leicht, denn wir haben jetzt, ich habe es angesprochen, wir sind da in einem Leistungsbereich unterwegs. Wir führen momentan die sogenannten Standortgespräche. Das heißt, die Jungs, jetzt aus unserer Mannschaft, die Jungs spielen nächstes Jahr U19. Während, also in der A-Jugend, nur der jüngere Jahrgang. Jede Altersstufe hat ja zwei Jahrgänge, während der jüngere Jahrgang. Momentan haben wir 23 Spieler oder 24. Davon ist einer jetzt schon jüngerer Jahrgang. Das heißt, wir haben den auch nächstes Jahr noch. Zum einfachen Rechnen einfach, 20 Leute gehen hoch. Rein vom Alter her. Sie gehen in die A-Jugend. Wir haben nur eine U19, das heißt nicht auch eine U18, sondern nur eine U19. Die früher hieß es A-Jugend. Es sind dann nächstes Jahr die Jahrgänge 2001 und 2002. Von uns rücken 20 nach. Aktuell sind aber schon, auch das nur eine Modellrechnung, 10 2001er, die jetzt jüngere Jahrgang sind, in der nächsten Saison ältere Jahrgang. Das heißt, du hast 30 Spieler. Das ist zu viel. Funktioniert nicht. Du musst 10 Spielern mitteilen, 10 von jetzt 20. Pass auf, drei Monate noch bis Mai, 1. Juni ist das letzte Spiel. Dann ist dein Weg hier zu Ende. Dann nimmst du vielleicht dem einen oder anderen komplett seine Vision. Die träumen natürlich alle davon, Fußballprofi zu werden. Diese Verantwortung musst du dir einfach mal ganz kurz überlegen, was du ihm mitteilst. Ich meine, es ist nicht gesagt, nur weil wir ihn jetzt vielleicht nicht weiter bei uns im Verein haben, dass er nicht doch Profi wird.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie sind da in der Altersklasse die Chancen, woanders runterzukommen in einem anderen NLZ?
Das ist schwierig, sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig.
Weil die wahrscheinlich alle ähnliche Probleme haben, dass da auf dem Weg nach oben eher der Trichter enger wird, oder?
Kommt halt drauf an. Wenn einer vom FC Bayern gesagt bekommt, du kommst nicht in die U19, dann kann er ja immer noch nach Ingolstadt. Genau. Ja, das ist so. Da sage ich jetzt auch nicht 2-1-Schäden. Wir haben natürlich nicht das Standing, das die Bayern haben, das Hoffenheim hat, das Stuttgart hat. Alles überragende, gerade die letzten beiden genannten, überragende Jugendarmut. Oder Hertha. Also da sind wir halt, wenn einer aus den Top 5 in Deutschland jetzt gesagt bekommt, pass mal auf, bei uns geht es nicht weiter, da ist die Luft halt extrem dünn, dann schafft er es vielleicht in einem anderen NLZ. Aber jetzt von Ingolstadt, also Hoffenheim und Stuttgart und Bayern und Hertha stehen halt nicht Schlange um jemanden, der unserer Einschätzung nach vielleicht bei uns nicht weiterkommt, dann aufzunehmen. Und das ist dann, das ist hart. Das ist wirklich schwer.
Ja und ich meine, und das ist ja die Regel. Die Ausnahme sind ja diejenigen, die es in dem Profifußball schaffen. Die Regel sind die vielen, die es nicht schaffen.
Ich weiß, hatten wir darüber gesprochen, wie viele aus meiner U17, U19 Nationalmannschaft damals Profi geworden sind? Nein. U17 Nationalmannschaft waren es, ich glaube, Nationalmannschaft. Wir sprechen nicht aus meiner Vereins- oder Mittelrheinauswahl, sondern wirklich nicht die deutsche U17 Nationalmannschaft. Von der U17 war es dann... Wir sprechen wirklich so 1. oder 2. Liga, 4, 5? Vielleicht, wenn wir das ein bisschen weiterfassen, 6, 7.
Und es sind jetzt schon nur die 21 bis 23 Deutschland-Mannauswahl in dieser Altersstrasse.
Am besten die Talente aus dem Jahrgang. Wenn ich jetzt in eine Stufe zurückgehe zur Mittelrheinauswahl, also zur regionalen Verbandsauswahl, ist halt einer. Also das war ich. Und das ist auch eine Form von Druck, mit der die Jungs umgehen müssen. Und da geht es dann darum, ihnen klar zu machen, dass das natürlich alles schade ist, aber das Leben nicht aufhört, nur weil es vielleicht zu Fußballprofi nicht reicht.
Wie viele solche Gespräche musstest du schon führen oder warst mit dabei?
Na jetzt habe ich vier. Also letztes Jahr bei der U21 schon einige. Da ist die Gewichtung aber eine andere.
Und wie geht man das an? Wird einem da eigentlich auch in der, zum Beispiel bei der Lizenz, wird einem da auch vermittelt, wie man solche Gespräche auch führen kann? Kann ja nicht jeder Mensch.
Das ist richtig. Oberste, maxime Ehrlichkeit. Ganz klar sagen, was los ist. Weil ich glaube, es ist nichts schlimmer für einen Jugendlichen. Da muss man glaube ich ein bisschen differenzieren zu einem Erwachsenen, der schon eine gewisse Lebenserfahrung hat und schon Dinge in diesem Geschäft mitgemacht hat. Einem Jugendlichen, der noch Träume und Visionen hat, irgendwas vorzumachen, um dann im April hinzugehen und zu sagen, du übrigens, wird doch nichts mit deinem Vertrag. Es gibt Fälle, da bist du dir jetzt einfach noch nicht sicher. Ja, da sagst du auch ganz klar, pass auf, das, was du dir am Anfang gespielt hast, war Mist. Dann hast du Sonderschichten gemacht. Man sieht ganz klar, du bist da und da besser geworden. Wir haben momentan noch ein kleines Fragezeichen. Aber wenn du so weitermachst wie in den letzten sechs Wochen, bist du auf dem richtigen Weg. Die Fälle gibt es, sind aber seltener, weil wir natürlich unsere Eindrücke über einen längeren Zeitraum zusammenfassen. Dann erkennst du einfach, wo es weitergeht und wo es nicht weitergeht. Ansonsten musst du wirklich offen und ehrlich sein. Dann musst du aber auch damit rechnen, dass der Spieler oder das Elternteil oder die Eltern sagen, dann hören wir jetzt aber zum Winter auf, weil mir der Aufwand nicht wert ist. Die Jungs fahren alle einen riesen Aufwand. Bei uns wohnen einige im Internat, aber viele kommen aus Nürnberg, aus München. Das heißt, die sind bis 16 Uhr in der Schule, setzen sich in den Zug oder in den Shuttle, kommen zum Training, machen am besten auf dem Weg noch die Hausaufgaben, sind abends um halb 10.10 Uhr zu Hause und gehen ins Bett, weil um 7 Uhr geht es schon wieder los zur Schule. Und das fünf Tage die Woche.
Wir haben jetzt so ein kleines Schlenker gemacht. Wir kamen ja quasi, wie man mit dem Druck umgeht, die aktive Seite. Und dann gibt es hier aber noch die rezipierende Seite, die berichtende Seite. Kann sich denn da überhaupt irgendwas verändern?
Da machst du jetzt ein ganz großes Gesprächsfeld auf. Wir werden immer damit leben müssen, wir von aktiver Seite, dass unsere Leistung bewertet wird. So. Die Frage ist, wird unsere Leistung bewertet? Oder werden wir als Deppen, Idioten, Trottel oder sonst was hingestellt? Das ist ein Unterschied.
Das ist quasi die Art und Weise. Ja, aber das ist doch eigentlich schon der wesentliche Punkt, dass quasi auch in der, in dem Reden über sportliche Leistung man eben bei der Sache bleiben sollte und dass auch hier, wie eigentlich bei allen Dingen im Leben, der Ton die Musik macht und die Wortwahl. Ja, dann haben wir doch eigentlich dieses große Thema dann doch ganz gut. Ganz gut abgelöst. Das war so ein bisschen der große Aspekt des Druckes im Fußball.
Wollen wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen auf die fußballerischen Aspekte eingehen. Da gab es auch einige Fragen. Ich fand zum Beispiel die von Dreifensterhaus ganz interessant. Was du sagen würdest, Ralph, wie hat sich denn der Innenverteidiger-Posten entwickelt in den letzten Jahren? Er schreibt so, er setzt es so im Vergleich zu Stürmer, Halbstürmer, falsche Neuen etc. Vieles wird interpretiert, mal so, mal so. Er hat aber das Gefühl, so der Innenverteidiger ist so die Konstante.
Ja und nein. Ja und nein, weil es kommt dann auch immer darauf an, in welcher Mannschaft du spielst. Also ein Innenverteidiger in Liverpool oder Manchester City hat sicherlich andere Aufgaben als ein Innenverteidiger von Stoke, Hannover und Stuttgart. Was sich für mich niemals ändern wird und da habe ich viele Diskussionen mit unheimlich fortschrittlichen Trainern geführt, ist für mich bleibt, ist die Kernaufgabe eines Innenverteidigers, ich betone die letzten Silben bewusst, immer noch das Tor zu verteidigen. Genauso wie ein Torwart für mich in seiner Kernaufgabe doch bitte den Ball festhalten soll, wenn er aufs Tor kommt. Das Aufgabenfeld hat sich aber erweitert. Ich beginne mal beim Torwart, auch wenn ich danach gefragt wurde, aber wenn ich sehe, wie zum Beispiel Alisson von Liverpool oder Ederson von City, was für ein Spielaufbau die betreiben. Wahnsinn. Da fang ich an zu jubeln in der Kommentatorenkabine. Also die Pässe hätte ich gerne spielen können. Außenstand, 80 Meter, in Fuß und der Stürmer sagt nur, vielen Dank. Wahnsinn. Würde aber alles nichts bringen, wenn die nicht auch einen Ball fangen könnten. Weil dann würde ich sagen, hier, du kriegst ein Spielertrikot, gehst auf die 6 und haust von da die diagonalen Bälle. Sind auch übrigens ganz gute Torhüter. Nur fällt das halt nicht so auf, weil die halt relativ wenig zu tun kriegen. Weil, und jetzt die Brücke zu den Innenverteidigern davor, die in ihrer Kernkompetenz, das Verteidigen, immer noch brutal gut sind, aber um ganz ganz nach vorne zu kommen, um nach ganz oben zu kommen und 75 Millionen zu kosten, wie Van Dyck, halt auch mit der Kugel am Ball im Spiel nach vorne, in der Spielgestaltung was leisten müssen. Die Basics sind die gleichen geblieben, die Grundvoraussetzungen. Damit wirst du es auch heute noch schaffen, aber halt nicht mehr so weit, weil dann halt noch andere Dinge gefragt sind, weil die Vereine, über die wir jetzt so sprechen, so Champions League Viertelfinale, das halt zu 90 Prozent Mannschaften sind, die aktiv spielen und das geht halt von ganz hinten los.
Ja, und dann haben wir noch eine Frage bekommen von 3FensterHaus, die schließt da dran an, da bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt drauf. Da wirst du vielleicht einen kurzen Moment nachdenken müssen. Wer sind deine Top 4 Innenverteidiger in diesem Jahrtausend?
In diesem Jahrtausend? Ok, das heißt Baresi fällt raus, aber der war ja auch Libero. Innenverteidiger, Cannavaro, ganz klar. Wie der um 2006 rum die Italiener geführt hat, wahnsinnig beeindruckend, überragend und vor allem, ich meine, das war jetzt körperlich kein Turm. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, müsst ihr dir nachschauen, wie groß er tatsächlich war, aber er ist nicht durch seine Körpergröße aufgefallen, aber über ein unheimlich aggressives, aber auch unheimlich intelligentes Abwehrspiel. Also das war schon ganz, ganz groß und vor allem, er hat die Mannschaft drum herum einfach unter Kontrolle gehabt. Also wirklich, das war schon, das war ganz großer Sport. Hast du es?
1,75.
1,75, was ja jetzt für einen Innenverteidiger nicht zwingend gerade im Maße ist, ja. Ähm, es ist jetzt unfair, dass du die Frage so gestellt hast, weil jetzt nenne ich vier. Ich hab die Frage nicht gestellt, weil du ein Fenster hast. Jetzt nenne ich vier und dann...
Und dann lässt du ganz viele weg bei dir anrufen.
Genau. Wenn wir jetzt mal komplett in die Neuzeit gehen, dann muss ich schon sagen, müssen wir van Dijk nennen. Der hat dann wiederum die Körpergröße. Auch da genau das, was Cannavaro ausgezeichnet hat, hat seine Mannschaft enorm unter Kontrolle. Also seine Ausstrahlung, seine Aura einfach ist... Ey, der spielt neben mir, da passiert nichts. Das gibt dir Sicherheit. Das gibt dir als zweiter IV Sicherheit. Das gibt dir als Außenverteidiger Sicherheit. Das ist schon richtig, richtig stark. Ist gut an der Kugel, gut in der Luft. Also von Daik müssen wir definitiv dazuzählen. Und jetzt musst du mir mal ein paar Sekunden geben zum Nachdenken, weil auf die Frage bin ich null vorbereitet.
Das ist ja auch der besondere Reiz davon. Fehlt jetzt in dieser Reihe noch so jemand wie Sergio Ramos?
Streitbar. Wenn Sergio Ramos und Pepe, den nenne ich direkt mit, sich nur auf das konzentrieren, was auf dem Fußballfeld mit Ball zu tun hat, gehören beide, Pepe müssen wir zwei, drei Jahre zurückgehen, oder vielleicht auch vier, gehören beide mit zu dem Besten, was es im europäischen Fußball gibt. Aggressivität, intelligentes Zweikampfverhalten, kompromisslos, am Boden und in der Luft, wenn sie sich halt nur auf das beschränken.
Was ist mit den großen Franzosen, die man so nennen kann? Ich versuche dir jetzt ein bisschen zu helfen, deine Innenverteidigung zu finden.
Leider war Virak kein Innenverteidiger. Er ist für mich einer der intelligentesten, besten Fußballer der letzten 30 Jahre.
Und was ist mit der neuen Generation an Innenverteidigung? Umtiti, Varan, wir sehen jetzt auch andere gute auch in der Bundesliga?
Varan und Batra habe ich beide relativ früh, als sie bei Barca und Real hochgekommen sind, gesehen. Und war schon unheimlich beeindruckt von ihrer Abgeklärtheit in jungen Jahren, von ihrer Athletik, von ihrer Kompromisslosigkeit. Was man immer bei der Bewertung solcher jungen Spieler beachten muss, wenn sie so früh hochkommen, das schützt natürlich Erwartungen. Wenn diese Entwicklung so weiterläuft, haben wir bald nur noch, oder bei jedem Spieler so weiterläuft, wie es mit 19, 20 aussehen könnte, haben wir nur noch Messis auf dem Platz stehen. Ich meine, jetzt sehen Fußballer. Weil dann werden alle nicht von diesen Planeten. Deswegen musst du bei diesen Spielern halt immer aufpassen. Die sind schon sehr, sehr früh auf extrem hohem Niveau. Und wenn sie sich nicht weiterentwickeln, halten sie ein gutes Niveau. Und wenn sie sich dann weiterentwickeln, werden sie vom anderen Planeten. Bei Batra war halt so ein bisschen das Problem früh weit gewesen. Und dann ist die Entwicklung nicht, sie ist zwar weitergegangen, aber nicht so extrem schnell, wie es in den Jahren davor einfach war. Es sind ja leider viele Dinge in seiner Karriere geschehen. Es wäre ein Frevel stagniert zu sagen, weil er spielt Profifußball auf hohem Niveau.
Aber gleichzeitig ist es vielleicht auch zu früh zu sagen, er ist in einer Top 4 aller Zeiten. Dafür ist es einfach nur zu früh.
Das gilt aber für beide. Puyols Mentalität definitiv.
Auch die Frisur.
Puyol's Aggressivität, Puyol's Spielintelligenz absolut. Puyol's Spiel mit Ball gut, aber nicht...
Dann muss er ja immer nur zu Xavi oder in Jester. Das war seine Aufgabe.
Das hat er hingekriegt. Oder Busquets dann schon. Da sind wir wieder bei der Frage, was hat sich verändert? Und in welcher Mannschaft spielst du?
Wir reden ja jetzt hier über 20 Jahre. Einen aktuellen Innenverteidiger aufgrund seines Ballspiels zu beurteilen, ist natürlich was anderes als einen von vor 20 Jahren.
Der musste halt auch nicht aufbauen. Wenn du viele Dinge zusammennimmst, musst du Puyol halt auch dazuzählen. Piquet, das war übrigens eine ganz spannende Entwicklung für mich. Die beiden zu sehen und dann Piquet ohne Puyol zu sehen. Du hast im ersten Jahr gemerkt, dass Piquet richtig... Puyol war derjenige, an dem sich Piquet angelehnt hat, in dessen Schatten er sich entwickeln konnte. Und auf einmal war Piquet derjenige, der jetzt quasi die Leaderrolle einnehmen musste. Und da hat er im ersten Jahr echt Probleme gehabt. Musste er sich erst mal darauf einstellen. Weil es ist halt geil, wenn du so einen Typen neben dir hast, egal ob Van Dijk oder Cannavaro oder Puyol, um jetzt mal die von eben genannten aufzugreifen, kannst du, du hast was zum Anlehnen. Du hast was, an dem du dich hochziehen kannst. Und auf einmal ist diese Stütze weg. Und dann stehst du da und merkst, scheiße, jetzt bin ich derjenige.
Gab es diesen Spieler für dich mal?
Ja, am extremsten war es eigentlich in der Mainzer-Zeit mit Noweski und Manu Friedrich. Noweski, damals mazedonischer Nationalspieler, Fußballer des Jahres. Manu Friedrich, zu dem Zeitpunkt auch Nationalspieler. Das war halt schon was anderes, wenn du mit solchen Leuten einfach zusammengespielt hast. Und ansonsten dann bei St. Pauli und auch später in Ingolstadt war das immer relativ gleichberechtigt. Also das war dann nicht so, beziehungsweise dann später, ne doch, es war gleichberechtigt. Also das war dann immer so auf Augenhöhe, das hat dann gut funktioniert. Nur wenn du halt neben solchen Figuren spielst, dann sind das die Lieder. Dahin hat sich Piquet ein Stück weit hin entwickelt. Er hat für mich trotzdem, und das findet hier, dass diese Kritik in Anführungsstrichen findet, auf einem so unfassbar hohen Niveau statt, dass es wirklich eigentlich frävel ist, das auszusprechen. Aber wenn man das dann halt so gegenüberstellt, fehlt Piquet der letzte Promillepunkt, um das auf den Platz zu bringen, was puiol. Dafür hat Piquet andere Fähigkeiten. Dafür ist Piquet deutlich besser im Spielaufbau. Auch wenn er sich in den letzten Monaten hin und wieder einiges geleistet hat. Aber die Fähigkeiten sind andere, weil 10 Jahre später ausgebildet worden oder 15 Jahre später.
Okay, wir können jetzt aber nicht aus diesem kleinen Teilsigment rausgehen, ohne noch kurz wenigstens über deutsche Innenverteidiger gesprochen zu haben.
Ähm, fällt dir jemand konkret ein?
Naja, also wir sind jetzt so ein bisschen die Nationen durchgegangen. Ich hab schon Chiellini, Bonucci, alle unter den Tisch fallen lassen, weil du mit Cannavaro schon einen Italiener gemacht hast.
Ja, aber trotzdem die beiden. Ich find die geil.
Die sind der absolute Wahnsinn.
Weißt du auch warum? Und dieser kleine Ausflug sei mir noch erlaubt. Weil ich finde, das, was die auf den Platz bringen, mit Buffon zusammen, und das versuche ich zum Beispiel meinen Innenverteidigern mitzugeben, Leute, ihr werdet in der Saison keine 25 Tore schießen. Aber was du an diesen Spielern siehst, und da fallen mir Szenen aus der letztjährigen Champions League ein, für die ist ein geiles Tackling in der 86. ein Tor. Wie die sich dann hochziehen, nicht nur wortwörtlich, sondern wie die sich dann einfach pushen und sagen, ey, verdammt nochmal, wir kriegen jetzt hier in den nächsten fünf Minuten kein beschissenes Tor mehr, ich will dieses Spiel gewinnen. Diesen Siegeswillen in der Verteidigungsarbeit, das zeichnet alle Innenverteidiger auf dem Niveau einfach aus. Die fühlen sich persönlich beleidigt, wenn sie ein Tor kassieren. Weil sie sagen, dieser 16er ist mein beschissenes Wohnzimmer, und du kommst hier nicht rein und machst hier einen auf was weiß ich wen und knallst das Ding in den Winkel. Solange ich hier stehe, nein. Und das vermitteln sie, das strahlen sie aus.
Und Chiellini und Bonucci, das glaubt man immer nicht, weil Juve und auch die italienische Nationalmannschaft generell immer ziemlich gut gegen den Ball steht, aber die haben eine so gute Restverteidigung. Du kannst mit vier Spielern auf den Strafraum zulaufen. Wenn die beiden im Strafraum sind, dann schaffen die es sich so hinzustellen, zusammen mit Buffon auch noch, dass sie sagen, ja, viel Glück jetzt erst mal mit dem Torerfolg. Das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt passieren. Das ist unglaublich. Das fand ich immer mit am tollsten bei denen. So, aber jetzt die Deutschen.
Jetzt Deutschland. Wenn wir jetzt in die jüngere Vergangenheit gehen, dann fallen einem Namen wie Mertesacker, Hummels, Boateng. Das sind wahrscheinlich so die ersten, die genannt werden. Süle versucht gerade, glaube ich, so ein bisschen den Zugang in diese Riegel zu finden. Boateng zur Guardiola-Zeit. Ich glaube, das ist einer der Spieler, der am meisten von Guardiola profitiert hat. Möglicherweise auch von der Art und Weise, wie Guardiola mit Ball spielen lässt, aber auch im Spiel gegen den Ball. Zu der Zeit eine Bank. Du hast nie das Gefühl gehabt, dass da auch nur im Ansatz irgendwas passieren könnte, weil der ist da. Da war er diese Figur, von der wir eben gesprochen haben, an der sich alle anderen hochziehen können.
Ich glaube, er hat unglaublich, weil du gerade gesagt hast, von der Guardiola-Zeit, was den Fußball angeht, aber davor noch von der Heinkiss-Zeit, was die Entwicklung angeht.
Was diese Mentalität angeht, was die persönliche Weiterentwicklung angeht.
Was der für eine Entwicklung gemacht hat in den zwei Jahren zuvor, war für mich unfassbar.
Absolut, da gebe ich dir recht. Mats Hummels hat, finde ich, das Spiel des Innenverteidigers lange Zeit in Deutschland auf eine neue Ebene gehoben, weil er dem Spiel eine gewisse Eleganz gegeben hat. Seine Ballbehandlung, seine Art und Weise, Zweikämpfe zu führen, hatte nichts mit Raubein zu tun, sondern war sehr geschickt.
Ganz viel ohne Faul.
Genau. So ein bisschen auch Philipp Lahm-mäßig, die sehr intelligent im Ballklauen sind oder waren, also im Fall Philipp Lahm waren, Mats Hummels sind. Die momentane Situation vermag ich jetzt gar nicht groß zu bewerten. Ich glaube, so wirklich hundertprozentig zufrieden, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass er es ist. Weil das auch für mich, und ich denke, das sieht eher ähnlich, das ist nicht das Leistungsvermögen, das man von ihm von vor zwei, drei, vier Jahren kennt. Aber darum geht es ja jetzt an der Stelle auch nicht, sondern er hat es halt für mich schon auf ein neues Level gehoben, beziehungsweise hat dem Innenverteidiger Spiel in Deutschland eine andere Farbe gegeben, eine andere Art und Weise. Und Süle hat dich noch angeführt, der momentan, ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, das ist so eine Symbiose aus dem Ganzen, mit ein bisschen mehr Einschlag, äh, Jerome Boateng. Das ist völlig wertfrei, das ist seine Art, das gibt seine Statur auch her.
Sehr ähnliche Statur.
Ich glaube, wenn er jetzt meint, oder wenn er jetzt anfängt, und meint, hier den Messi machen zu müssen, nein, so realistisch ist er schon selbst, dass er weiß, ok, pass auf, das ist mein Körper, das sind meine Stärken, und die setze ich entsprechend ein. Und wir sollten vielleicht auch mal kurz weg vom FC Bayern. Wir waren bei Per Mertesacker, der auch sehr, sehr intelligent gespielt, also, Per ist ein überragender Typ, auch ein überragend intelligenter Typ, und genauso hat er auch Fußball gespielt. Auch da wieder die Mannschaft steht im Vordergrund. Bei Per ist es, und war es, und ist es die Mannschaft, ist es die Gemeinschaft. Das hast du gemerkt in der Art und Weise, wie er spielt, wie er einfach seine Interviews geführt hat. Die Sache stand im Vordergrund, und die Art und Weise auch wieder. Es ging darum, den Ball zu gewinnen, zu Mitspieler zu spielen, und damit war der Job erledigt.
Aber ist Deutschland ein guter Innenverteidiger-Standort? Aktuell im Jahr 2018, wenn ich beobachte, dass wir sehr viele französische Innenverteidiger haben, dass manche der deutschen etablierten Innenverteidiger so langsam vielleicht dann auch der Körper das absolute Maximum vielleicht überschritten hat, also mit großem Fragezeichen, lasse ich mich gerne vom Gegenteil überzeugen, aber manchmal im Sprint hat man bei dem einen oder anderen schon das Gefühl gehabt, ein bisschen langsamer als noch vor ein, zwei Jahren. Weil das war doch mal oder vielleicht habe ich da auch einen falschen historischen Blick, aber die Innenverteidiger-Schule, und da kann man dann noch die Position des Liberals mit reinrechnen, weil der ja viel übernommen hat, was jetzt moderne Innenverteidiger jetzt dann selbst erledigen, das war ja immer schon sowas genuin-deutsches. Und das war zusammen mit einem Torhüter, dem man nachts nicht begegnen möchte, der aber alles von der Linie kratzt und dafür aber auch jeden Abschlag ins Aushaut, war das ja immer das Fundament der deutschen Nationalmannschaft über ganz viele Jahrzehnte.
Die Frage, die mir jetzt zuerst in den Sinn kommt, als Antwort auf deine Frage, als Gegenfrage quasi, müssen wir das nicht in einen größeren Kontext stellen. Das heißt, weg davon, ist Deutschland ein guter Standort für Innenverteidiger, sondern was hat das mit der Art und Weise, wie in Deutschland Fußball gespielt wird, zu tun? Heißt, konzentrieren wir uns mehr auf Spiel gegen den Ball oder konzentrieren wir uns auf das Spiel mit dem Ball? Wie ich eben gesagt habe, wenn du gewisse Basics mitbringst, reicht das für Niveau X, aber nicht für Weltspitze, weil dann die Anforderungen andere sind. Wenn man jetzt einfach mal sieht, wie in den letzten Jahren Fußball gespielt wird in der Bundesliga, mit ganz wenigen Ausnahmen, stand das Spiel gegen den Ball sehr häufig im Fokus. Es ging darum, erst mal gut zu stehen und dann schnell umzuschalten, weniger selber aktiv das Spiel zu gestalten. Dementsprechend brauchst du natürlich andere Innen- oder andere Abwehrspieler, als wenn du eine Mannschaft bist, die viel den Ball hat und dann quasi die Innenverteidiger schon zum aktiven Spielaufbau, zur aktiven Spielgestaltung braucht. Weil bei der einen brauchst du die Verteidiger, bei der anderen Variante brauchst du halt die spielenden Verteidiger, die aber trotzdem die Basics noch können sollten. Wenn man das jetzt quasi, wenn man jetzt so ein paar Denkstufen überspringt, landen wir halt da, dass dieses viele Spiel gegen den Ball dazu geführt hat, dass momentan in der absoluten Weltspitze eben kein Van Dyck aus Deutschland kommt. Weil die Ausbildung eine ganz andere ist, weil die Anforderungen andere sind, weil die ganze Spielidee, die ganze Spielphilosophie, die dahinter steckt, das nicht bedingt. Trainer wie Nagelsmann zum Beispiel versuchen das natürlich, auch immer wieder reinzubringen, aber das ist eine Geschichte, die kannst du nicht. Innerhalb von zwei Saisons kannst du dir diese Spieler nicht züchten, aber halt dir nicht ausbilden.
Ja, aber man sieht es ja vielleicht ganz gut an Kevin Vogt und wie Julian Nagelsmann ihn dann eingesetzt hat, im Vergleich zu den Stationen davor. Auf einmal war Kevin Vogt so eine Art Quarterback, hat entweder versucht, den Ball zu spielen auf den Sechser, der dann weiter verteilt hat, oder hat aber auch selber den Spiel auf Bahnen gekürbelt. Und das ist ja, ohne das werten zu werden, aber das ist ja einfach interessant, wie unterschiedlich dieser Spieler eingesetzt wurde von unterschiedlichen Tränen, die er hatte.
Richtig. Dann weißt du ja, worauf ich hinaus möchte. Also wie du siehst, die klassische oder die einfache Beantwortung dieser Frage ist, selbst da braucht es wirklich dann ein eigenes Tribünengespräch. Das würde jetzt sehr weit führen.
Okay, wir müssen vielleicht mal einfach durch die Hörerfragen so ein bisschen durchskippen. Ich halte mich auch jetzt zurück, dass wir da ein bisschen durchkommen. Ich weiß nicht, Frank, ob du dir schon eine rausgesucht hast, die du jetzt gerne stellen wollen würdest.
Doktor Unmöglich fragt, mich würde interessieren, wie Ralph sein Steak am liebsten mag. Medium, blutig oder doch aus Gold? Oder anders gefragt, was sagt der Ex-Profi Gunesch und der Trainer Gunesch zu solchen Aktionen? Also ich spiele natürlich, um Kontext zu liefern. Das geht um die Steak-Affäre, Ribéry.
Also ich mag meinen Steak tatsächlich medium. Früher war ich mehr so well done, bis meine Freundin mir zwei Verbalorfeigen verteilt hat und gesagt hat, nein, wir essen jetzt medium. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass es tatsächlich schmeckt. Also ich fange mal, ich fange mal so an. So ein goldenes Steak reizt mich jetzt halt nicht wirklich. So, das zum einen. Zum anderen. Und damit müssen wir uns, glaube ich, abfinden, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, in dem auch solche Dinge Anklang finden. Wir sind eine Instagram-Generation und ich glaube nicht, dass das Steak anders ist. Ich glaube, dass das Steak wunderbar schmeckt. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher. Ich war noch nicht da und werde es sehr wahrscheinlich auch nicht tun, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass es gut schmeckt. Das Gold sieht halt für Instagram gut aus. So, und jeder Marketing-PR-Berater wird dem, ich weiß gar nicht, wie der heißt, dem Koch... Salt Bae. Ist der überhaupt Koch oder verkauft der das nur? Ich würde sagen, ich nehme dich hier als Role Model für perfektes Marketing. Ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung, weil wir sind jetzt in dieser Generation. Kann man gut finden, kann man doof finden?
Und davon lebt es, glaube ich. Dass es die Hälfte gut findet und die andere Hälfte doof. Oder große Teile.
Dass du dich als Fußballer, wenn du sowas postest, oder in der Art und Weise, dass du dich gerade als Fußballer ein Stück weit angreifbar machst, ist jetzt auch keine große Überraschung. Wir könnten jetzt anfangen, über soziale Medien zu diskutieren und über die Diskussionskultur. Ist zwar schade, musst du aber mit Leben können, dass du auch entsprechende Reaktionen bekommst. Die Frage ist nur, wie reagierst du darauf?
Wie immer macht der Ton die Musik.
Ich kann verstehen, nachvollziehen, unabhängig von Ribery, dass jeder, und so würde es euch auch gehen, wenn ihr auf ein Posting nur durchbeleidigt werden würdet. Ich hab's mir nicht durchgelesen, aber das stand bestimmt nicht nur drin. Also nee, das mit dem Steak finde ich jetzt uncool. Da standen sicherlich auch ganz andere Dinge drin.
Davon ist auszugehen, ja.
Dass du dann irgendwann mal sagst, sag mal, habt ihr, hackt ihr noch ganz sauber? So, ob ich jetzt allerdings mit dieser Wortwahl darauf reagieren muss, stelle ich jetzt mal ganz arg zur Diskussion. Ich kann verstehen, dass er sich aufregt. Ja, die Wortwahl halte ich jetzt für maximal unglücklich, ist auch nicht der Weg, den ich gewählt hätte. Aber das kommt halt dabei rum, wenn man Spieler machen lässt ohne PR-Waschmaschine. Und auch da wieder, wir sind alle Menschen und die einen haben das Zeug zum Raketenwissenschaftler im CERN in Bern, Zürich, und die anderen wählen halt diese Formulierung. Das ist völlig, ist halt so. Ich hätte es nicht so gewählt, dass es seine Form damit umzugehen, bzw. das ist seine Ausdrucksweise für die Kritik. Von Vereins-Trainer-Seite aus hat man ja anscheinend da reagiert und gesagt, pass auf, da kann man so nicht mit umgehen. Mich stört, also an der ganzen Geschichte stört mich, also am ehesten stört mich die, oder es sind zwei Dinge, die mich stören. Zum einen ist das die Berichterstattung über das Ursprungsposting des Stakes, weil da auch extrem viel verzerrt wurde. Und mit Berichterstattung meine ich insgesamt Reaktion darauf, inklusive aller Kommentare. Und zum anderen halt...
Da wird natürlich diese Polarisierung, die da entsteht, wird natürlich gefördert durch die Art der Berichterstattung.
Total befeuert, ja. Und zum anderen ist das dann halt die Reaktion und Ausdrucksweise von Ribery gewesen, wo ich auch zu denen gehöre, die das halt nicht so inkul finden. Aber damit ist das Ding auch für mich... Ja, ist halt so. Punkt.
Ich finde, das reicht auch. Also ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir über das Goldsteak von Ribery im Rasenfunk überhaupt mal sprechen.
Entschuldigung, du hast mit diesem Gossip angefangen.
Ich habe aus vielen Fragen diese ausgewählt.
Nee, das ist ja auch in Ordnung. Die Frage ist ja auch legitim. Nur, das ist eigentlich relativ weit weg von dem, was wir sonst machen. Und ich finde, wir haben es ganz gut umrissen. Bayerndusel fragt noch, sammelt ihr Fußballer auch Grounds wie normale Fans?
Die Frage habe ich, die habe ich schon gesehen.
Also wird in der Kabine schon mal mit einem exotischen Länderpunkt gepreit. Und wenn ja, dann will er wissen, ob du die Groundhopper-App nutzt.
Selbstverständlich nutze ich die Groundhopper-App. Ich habe lange Zeit mit Mike vom Übersteiger, ehemals Übersteiger, Entschuldigung. Oder wie formuliert man das am besten? Mike, der mal beim Übersteiger, ist so rum. Genau, jetzt auch sehr aktiv im Millanturn, einer der Hauptprotagonisten. Lange Zeit darüber diskutiert, ob ich meine Spiele als Aktiver denn miteintragen darf. Da habe ich mir natürlich ganz klar auf der Meinung, dass ich das darf. Weil ich war ja, 45 Minuten muss man oder sollte man quasi im Stadion, auf dem Fußballplatz, was auch immer sein. Ich war es 90 Minuten, also länger als er. Hundertprozentig war ich immer länger als er im Stadion. Insofern lasse ich mir da nichts reinreden. Ja, ich nutze es. Nein, man vergleicht das nicht. Was ich aber tue, ist, dass ich, wenn ich so die Wege meiner ehemaligen Mitspieler, mit denen ich halt noch engeren Kontakt habe, verfolge. Als ich noch nicht zum Beispiel in Wembley war zu dem Zeitpunkt, oder in Manchester, und Max Kruse durfte dort spielen, habe ich schon so geschrieben, so ein bisschen heidisch bin ich ja, schon auf dich. Weil die dürfen halt nicht nur in dem Stadion sein, sondern die dürfen da auch spielen. Das ist ja dann nochmal was ganz anderes. Also ich kenne jetzt eigentlich keinen Fußballer, der so diese Affinität dazu hat, wie ich sie habe. Aber mir macht das großen Spaß. Und das ist dann schon auch ein Thema, wenn ich dann gerade mit Ex-Mitspielern, die jetzt aktuell noch spielen, schreibe, spreche, wo ich dann halt auch zu Danny da Costa, mit dem ich immer noch einen sehr, sehr guten, freundschaftlichen Draht pflege, wo der dann halt international alles auftauchen darf. Puh, das würde sich sehr gut, hätte sich gut in meiner Vita gemacht, aber auch in meiner Groundhopper-App. Und ja, ich darf auch in die Ukraine übrigens. Also jetzt nach Tcharkiv gegen Donetsk werde ich auch dank meines Jobs hinkommen können. Und das wird dann auch ein ganz exotischer, ein ganz exotischer Ground, wobei das ist da nicht der erste in Ukraine. Denn in Kiew beim Champions League-Finale war ich schon, aber ansonsten wäre ich relativ selten nach Tcharkiv gekommen.
Das ist so anzunehmen. Und du hast unseren ungeteilten Neid und den, den alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, dem Konkurrenzsieger gesagt.
Also wenn du jetzt aber parallel Wetter Tcharkiv eingebst, weiß ich nicht, ob dein Neid immer noch so groß ist.
Mein Mitleid hält sich in engem Grenzen.
Das wird richtig. Das wird schattig, habe ich gelesen.
Du bist ja dann immerhin in dem Pressebereich da. Ich stand in Rom beim letzten Auswärtsspiel, da eintracht vier Stunden im Regen bei zwei Grad.
Auf der Tribüne wird es auch nicht wärmer sein.
Nächste Frage. Frank, hast du dir eine rausgesucht schon? Dann lege ich mit der Sorbe nach. Der hat gefragt, hast du Lieblingsfans Szenen außer St. Pauli? Gibt es vielleicht auch negative Meinungen zu einzelnen Fanszenen? Ich weiß, dünnes Eis, aber da musst du drüber.
Das ist sehr, sehr dünnes Eis.
Wird keiner, komm.
Genau so dünnes Eis, weil ich habe dir jetzt gerade noch kurz über die Aussage drüber nachgedacht zum Thema Ribery, als ich den Raketenwissenschaftler angesprochen habe. Ich wollte damit nur ausdrücken, dass Menschen ganz unterschiedlich mit solchen Dingen umgehen und unterschiedliche Reaktionen zeigen. Und Ribery hat halt diese gewählt. Fanszenen. Sankt Pauli brauchen wir nicht drüber diskutieren. Warum, wieso, weshalb. Da ist mir tatsächlich auch Babelsberg sehr sympathisch. Und ich weiß, dass viele meiner... Ich habe ja auch ein Jahr in Mainz gespielt und habe auch weiterhin einen guten Draht zum Verein und zu dem ein oder anderen aus der Fanszene und drum herum und so. Und wenn ich jetzt sage, dass das, was die Eintracht in den letzten Wochen überwiegend abliefert, mir gefällt, dann kriege ich wahrscheinlich ganz viel Ärger. Aber das hat auch ein bisschen mit dem Verhalten des Präsidenten seinen Aussagen zu tun, seiner klaren Positionierung, die die Fans in vielen Aktionen auch übernommen haben. Und was die halt sonst so abliefern, das ist schon beeindruckend. So gerade im Hinblick auf Stimmung, auf Lautstärke, auf Präsenz in der Quantität. Klar, jetzt werden natürlich wieder einige anfangen und sagen, ja, aber die Pyros. Diese Diskussion fangen wir jetzt hier nicht an. Ich möchte nur sagen, dass mir Eintracht tatsächlich in den letzten Monaten, nicht nur weil ich oder vielleicht auch weil ich durch Danny halt dann auch natürlich häufiger nach Frankfurt geschaut habe, mir positiv aufgefallen ist. Und ich habe dann nämlich dann auch mal erkundigt, ich sage mal, ist euer Präsident, ist der gute Marketing oder ist der wirklich so? Sagt er, nee, das ist tatsächlich ein ziemlich geiler Typ. Und das kannst du dem schon so glauben. Und das finde ich halt noch viel besser, wenn das jemand so tut. Darüber hinaus, wenn ich jetzt sage, FC Bayern-Fanszene werden viele sicherlich lachen, weil die Allianz Arena jetzt ganz selten dafür bekannt ist, wirklich als Hexenkessel zu explodieren. Dazu haben wir nur eine kleine Geschichte. Meine Freundin ist nicht so der große Bayern-Fan. Sie ist halt Borussia Dortmund-Fan. Und wir waren in Madrid letztes Jahr. Was war das, Viertel- oder Halbfinale? Nee, Halbfinale war Atletico gegen Real, Viertelfinale. Und das war das erste FC Bayern-Auswärtsspiel für sie. Wir waren so ein, zwei Mal vorher in der Allianz Arena, aber sie war noch nie mit den Bayern auswärts international. Und als überzeugte Borussia Dortmund-Anhängerin hat sie zu mir, wir waren halt auch oben im Blog, hat sie zu mir tatsächlich gesagt, Ralph, ich muss meine Meinung über die Bayern-Fans-Szene revidieren. Das ist schon extrem stark, was die auswärts abliefern. Betonung lag tatsächlich auf auswärts. Das Problem, auch das soll jetzt keine Stimmungsdiskussion, Allianz Arena, aber die Anzahl, die auswärts mitfährt, wenn du die halt in eine 70.000-Mann-Arena zu Hause packst, wird überschaubar. Aber auch da ist mir die Szene, und das hat nicht nur sie bestätigt, sondern auch einige andere, auch da positiv aufgefallen. Zusätzlich zu dem Engagement um Kurt Landauer und was alles dazugehört, finde ich sehr, sehr positiv. Deswegen erwähne ich das hier auch. Ansonsten negativ wäre ein zu dünnes Eis, weil das ist eine sehr, sehr subjektive Wahrnehmung, die ich gar nicht mal wirklich zutreffen muss, oder die generell zutreffen muss, sondern das bezieht sich dann auf einzelne Spiele, die ich einfach vor allem als St. Pauli-Spieler mitgemacht habe. Es ist bekannt, welche Fanszenen da jetzt nicht unbedingt sich nach dem Spiel noch freundschaftlich auf dem Bier treffen. Deswegen skippe ich diese Frage ein Stück weit. Und ich überlege gerade, ob es sonst noch irgendwie positiv auf... Ja, die Bremer, muss ich sagen, auch häufiger mal durch sehr positive Aktionen aufgefallen. Die Nürnberger, ich weiß, alle FCI-Fans werden jetzt auch mit mir schimpfen, aber wenn ich an die Corio denke, die sie 2014 bei uns im Stadion abgezogen haben als Auswärtsmannschaft im Gästeblock im Audi-Sportpark, das war schon ordentlich. Du kannst bei fast allen ganz viele positive Aspekte rausheben. Das würde jetzt den anderen auch fast nicht gerecht werden, wenn ich sie nicht nenne, weil es gibt Vereine, die mag ich, es gibt Vereine, die mag ich nicht. Aber was ich allen Fans sehen unterstelle, zugute halte, ist, dass sie mit voller Leidenschaft bei ihrem Verein sind und ihn auf verschiedenste Arten und Weisen unterstützen. Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass es auch Vereine gibt, die ich tatsächlich einfach nicht mag. Aber die Fans sehen und die Anerkennung dafür, die haben bei mir fast alle.
Ein bisschen anschließend an die Frage, hat Netzroller so im Kontext der Berufswahl, also sprich der Vereinswahl für den Kicker, auch gefragt, ob die Fanszene da irgendwie ein Argument ist, zu einem Verein zu gehen oder nicht. Oder ist es da tatsächlich so, wie wir das vorher schon beim Trainer gesagt haben, naja, so oft ist man nicht in der Rolle, die Wahl groß zu haben, zu sagen, jetzt habe ich aus fünf Vereinen die Wahl und dann suche ich mir den aus, wo mir dann auch nur die Fanszene gut gefällt.
Fans, das ist auch wieder schwer zu beantworten, weil es auch bei Fußballern oder bei Spielern unterschiedliche Ansätze oder unterschiedliche Berufsauffassungen gibt. Die einen sind darauf aus, ich habe jetzt 10, 12, 14, 15 Jahre Zeit und hole das Maximum an Euros, Dollars, was auch immer raus und danach habe ich damit nichts mehr zu tun. Die anderen sehen das ein bisschen, nehmen es persönlicher. Trotzdem bei allen glaube ich, dass es eine Rolle spielen kann, aber keine Hauptentscheidende. Also du wirst nicht irgendwo hinwechseln, wo du nur die Hälfte verdienst, aber die Fans nett sind. Muss man ganz platt zu formulieren. Wenn du jetzt eine Sache hast, wo ähnliches Gehalt, sportliche Perspektive, dann können Dinge schon so ein bisschen das Zünglein an der Waage sein. Aber mehr als das Zünglein an der Waage nicht, auch wenn es natürlich deutlich mehr Spaß macht, wenn du halt so eine Fanszene wie zum Beispiel die eben genannten hast.
Ja, logisch. Daran schließt auch so ein bisschen Nikolaj seine Frage an. Er fragt, wo hört denn dein Fan-Heart auf zu schlagen und wo beginnt dein Job? Er bezieht es noch so ein bisschen auf deine Profizeit und dahinter steht so ein bisschen die Frage. Wir wissen von dir, dass du sehr auf Fanszenen guckst und dich damit auch sehr weit identifizieren kannst. Ist das noch ein Sonderfall unter Fußballprofis? Wie würdest du es einschätzen?
Sonderfall nicht, aber auch nicht unbedingt die Mehrheit. Irgendwas dazwischen ist es schon. Wo fängt es an, wo hört es auf? Es ist nicht leicht, wenn du, ich nehme mal die Formulierung, wenn du die Berufsauffassung hast, dass du viele Dinge persönlich nimmst, auch zu sagen, ok, pass auf, zu dem Verein wechsle ich nicht oder sowas mache ich nicht. Wir hatten ja das Thema, das ist ja dann noch tatsächlich in einer Talkrunde im deutschen Fernsehen gelandet, mit RB damals bei mir. Da war tatsächlich für mich die Entscheidung, dass ich diesen Schritt nicht gehe. Es haben eigentlich ganz viele Dinge dafür gesprochen, aber meine persönliche Einstellung hat nicht dafür gesprochen. Das ist als Trainer nicht zwingend leichter, weil du halt dann nicht, auch da hast du in den allerwenigsten Fällen tatsächlich die Auswahl aus sechs Vereinen und sagst, ok, pass auf, da können jetzt auch weiche Faktoren eine Rolle spielen, weil ich kann es mir erlauben. Ich habe immer versucht und werde das auch als Trainer versuchen, und jetzt sprechen wir über einen ganz, ganz hypothetischen Part meiner Zukunft, weil wer weiß, ob ich jemals überhaupt in diese Situation komme, auch da mir treu zu bleiben. Das heißt, ich würde wahrscheinlich ganz, ganz viele Dinge, ganz, ganz viele Aussagen komisch wirken lassen, wenn ich mich jetzt zu meinem Job beim HSV reißen würde. Das würde halt komisch wirken. Vielleicht würde man es mir in dem Moment auch verzeihen, weil man sagt, ok, pass auf, das ist jetzt seine Chance, in den Profifußball zu kommen. Und ein Verein mit unheimlich viel Potenzial.
Du hättest aber gleichzeitig auch da einen schwereren Stand. Also du bist ja dann dessen bewusst. Da würde dann wahrscheinlich das Tribünengespräch das letzte nochmal ein paar Zusatzdownloads bekommen, weil die Leute nochmal nach der Stelle suchen, wo du über den HSV sprichst.
Ja, das sind alles oder viele Dinge, die dann in solche Entscheidungsfindungen mit einfließen. Wie viel Gewicht man dem ganzen gibt, das entscheidet dann letztendlich jeder Spieler, jeder Trainer für sich selber. Da kann ich nicht für die anderen sprechen. Ich weiß, dass Danny es jetzt zum Beispiel wahnsinnig genießt, solche Zuschauer im Rücken zu haben. So, wenn du das dann mal mitgemacht hast und weißt einfach, was das für ein Faustband ist, dann genießt du das einfach. Deswegen glaube ich, dass er das jetzt auch ein Stück weit mit einfließen lassen würde. Und das ist sicherlich auch ein Grund, warum er jetzt schon verlängert hat. Also klar, es wird sich auch auf anderen Ebenen gelohnt haben. Aber trotzdem, das hat er auch damals, als ich ihn für DAZN nach seinem Doppelpack gegen Rom interviewt habe, hat er das ja hervorgehoben. Und auch wenn wir dann so privat geschrieben haben und wir kommen auf das Thema Fußball, sind das Dinge, die er einfach anspricht, weil es ihm Spaß macht.
Glaubst du, die Fans spielen für einen Spieler eine andere Rolle als für einen Trainer? Denn der Spieler ist ja ein Teil einer Gruppe und der Trainer steht exponierter da?
Der Trainer steht exponierter und der Trainer ist der erste, dessen Kopf gefordert wird. In den seltensten Fällen rufen die Fans dann hier Gunesch raus, weil ich noch die Nummer 11 habe oder die 26. Sondern die fordern den Kopf des Trainers. Insofern ist das auch immer, finde ich gut, dass die allermeisten Trainer sich bei sowas sehr häufig im Hintergrund halten. Zwar versuchen immer eine Brücke zwischen Mannschaft und Fans zu schlagen, aber nicht selber die Brücke sind.
Also was macht es jetzt damit, dass sie nicht selber mit in die Kurve gehen und sich persönlich feiern lassen?
Du erlebst es ja wirklich ganz selten, dass Trainer aktiv nach dem Spiel den Weg in die Kurve suchen. Ich spreche jetzt gar nicht mal davon, was Kloppo zum Beispiel macht, dass er seine Spieler abklatscht und dann auch mal Richtung Fans winkt. Das ist alles gut, das gehört dazu. Aber so Geschichten wie, in Deutschland ist es ja dann USOS, in anderen Ländern tatsächlich weniger, dass Spieler dann auch konkret Richtung Kurve gehen und abklatschen, Welle machen, was auch immer. Und da halten sich ja Trainer immer komplett zurück, weil sie natürlich auch sagen, hey, die Mannschaft hat gespielt, ich habe sie nur aufgestellt. Spielen sie sich gar nicht in den Vordergrund, weil sie halt genau wissen, wie es in dem Geschäft läuft.
Das haben mir tatsächlich die Jungs von The Enfit Rap erzählt. Das sind Liverpooler Podcaster, mit denen ich eine Sendung gemacht habe. Dass Klopp mal nach einem sehr wichtigen Spiel tatsächlich in die Kurve gegangen ist, um sich zu bedanken. Das war ein Unentschieden in letzter Minute gegen Bournemouth. Oder irgendwo so was aus dieser Kategorie, in der Phase, wo er noch relativ frisch bei Liverpool war. Da waren die tatsächlich eher irritiert, weil er sich bei den Fans bedanken wollte. Bei denen kam es so an, als wollte er mit ihnen feiern, dass man noch einen Punkt geholt hätte zu Hause in letzter Sekunde. Das kam ein bisschen falsch an.
Man kennt das in England ja gar nicht. Wenn man mal in Premier League Stadien war oder falls das im Fernsehen so halbwegs durchkommt, das Spielfeld ist sehr schnell leer. Da gibt es auch keinen Kreis oder so. Da wird abgeklatscht, Schiedsrichter shake hands und vielleicht auf dem Weg zur Kabine noch mal Richtung Fan-Kurve gewunken. Auch das völlig wertfrei, dieses Celebrieren der dritten Halbzeit. Ich nenne es mal dritte Halbzeit, auch wenn sie eigentlich eine andere Bedeutung hat. Auf dem Feld mit der Fan-Kurve zusammen gibt es in Spanien und in England gar nicht. Wie es in Italien und Frankreich ist, weiß ich nicht, dafür habe ich zu wenig Spiele gesehen. Aber auch in Spanien ist das Stadion nach fünf Minuten leer. Du stehst da und hier in Deutschland hast du nach einer halben Stunde die Tribünen, zwar mit vielen Lücken, aber sie sind gefüllt. In Spanien schließen die nach 20 Minuten die Tore. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, die Kölner in Arsenal, also in London, und ich hatte damals die Tickets über Moritz Folz bekommen. Das waren so Scouting-Tickets, relativ zentral hinter der Arsenal-Bank. Und die Kölner haben ja ein Theater da veranstaltet, auch noch 20 Minuten nach dem Spiel. Und dann habe ich mich nur mit einem Ordner unterhalten, weil er sagte so, und jetzt alle raus. Und ich habe ihm gesagt, ja, normalerweise hier 15, 20 Minuten nach Schluss 5 haben wir Feierabend. Ich habe gesagt, dann komm mal nach Deutschland. Absolut.
Ja, was Klopp auch mal gemacht hat, nach einem wirklich wichtigen Sieg, wollte er dann zusammen mit der Mannschaft das Hey, Hey, Hey machen, wo du eben die Arme hoch reißt.
Das kennt keiner.
Das hat weder die Mannschaft verstanden, noch The Cop hat es verstanden. Das muss ganz lustig ausgesehen haben. Inzwischen wissen sie aber, was er meint. Er macht es aber auch nicht mehr so häufig. Und dann haben sie mir erzählt, David Wagner hat es bei Hadass Vita dann tatsächlich etablieren müssen. Als sie aufgestiegen sind, da wurde es dann aber gemacht. Also so ein bisschen deutsche Fan-Kultur kam dann rüber auf die Insel. Das ist ja schön zu wissen. Wollen wir mal mit den nächsten Fragen weitermachen. Ein kleiner Themen-Switch. Aribo hat ein bisschen mehr, jetzt geht es wieder mehr um den Profi-Fußball und die Vorbereitung. Er schreibt, man hört ja häufig davon, dass bei englischen Wochen die entsprechenden Mannschaften gar nicht mehr gegnerspezifisch sich im Training einstellen können, sondern sich hauptsächlich auf theoretischer Basis im Videoraum vorbereiten. Ist das richtig? Und ist die Warnung auch richtig, dass das bei kleineren Teams in Anführungszeichen nicht so abläuft?
Die Annahme ist richtig, ja. Ganz einfache Begründung, du hast gar nicht die Zeit dafür. Als ich am Wochenende Arsenal gegen Chelsea begleiten durfte, in der Vorbereitung, da ich die Tage vorher in London war, habe ich mir ein paar Tageszeitungen mitgenommen. Und da war eine Grafik drin über die Ruhephasen Chelseas seit Mitte November. Da waren bis auf zwei Ausnahmen immer nur drei Tage zwischen zwei Spielen. Das waren, glaube ich, drei Ausnahmen. Einmal waren es vier, einmal fünf. In dieser Zwischenzeit hast du nicht die Zeit, dich dann praktisch auf den kommenden Gegner vorzubereiten. Du darfst ja nicht vergessen, du spielst. Bei International war es dann so, dass du erst am nächsten Tag wieder zurück reist. Dann hast du einen Trainingstag und dann reist du schon wieder zum nächsten Spiel. Dieser eine Trainingstag ist aber der zweite Tag nach dem Spiel. Das bedeutet, das ist eigentlich der Tag, an dem du normalerweise in einem klassischen Rhythmus freigebst, weil das der Tag ist, an dem du die Belastung am meisten spürst. Das heißt, da kannst du die Spieler körperlich gar nicht so sehr belasten, sondern kannst sie theoretisch belasten. Dass du sagst, wir schauen uns jetzt mal ein Video an und das und das erwarte ich von euch. Hast aber gar nicht die Zeit, wirklich diese Mechanismen einzustudieren und die kannst du nicht in 30 Minuten mit zwei Übungen einstudieren, um sie darauf vorzubereiten, um ihnen auch praktisch das zu zeigen, was du theoretisch ihnen vorher gezeigt hast und vielleicht auch von ihnen verlangst. Aber es ist eine Sache, ob ich zu dir sage, Max, wir gehen jetzt hier in den Garten und dann baust du mir bitte drei Schneemänner mit einem Durchmesser von so und so und der eine soll bitte ein Viereck sein. Oder ob ich mit dir zusammen rausgehe und dir zeige, wie machst du das. Das sind zwei Paar Schuhe. Und bei solchen Mannschaften, die halt international vertreten sind, dann noch im Pokal und vielleicht auch zwei Mannschaften mehr in der Liga haben und und und, beschränkt sich das tatsächlich auf theoretische Vorbereitung. Und auch das musst du lernen. Und auch diese Stressresistenz ist auch eine der Dinge, auf die dann halt geschaut wird.
Ist es dann aber eine Frage der Spielerqualität, wie gut das funktioniert?
Ja, das ist eine Frage der Spielerqualität. Das ist eine Frage deiner Qualität in der Arbeit der Vorbereitung, also in der die Arbeit in der Vorbereitung, in der Saisonvorbereitung. Wie viel von deinen eigenen Ideen vermittelst du den Spielern konkret, auf die du, also wie komplexes dein Werkzeug hast, dass du dann während der Saison quasi darauf zugreifen kannst, weil du halt Plan A, B und C hast.
Entsteht aber wahrscheinlich ja immer aus der Not heraus. Du hast gerade gesagt, europäische Belastung. Kurzer Spielrhythmus, kurze Abstände.
Das sind Dinge, die dann quasi dazu führen.
Das heißt, das macht man auch nur, wenn man in der Not ist. Wenn man die Zeit hat, dann greift man schon, wenn es irgendwie geht, auf das Training zurück.
Genau, genau. Wenn man sieht, die Meistersaison Chelsea's vor zwei Jahren international nicht dabei gewesen. Alle anderen haben sich auch in den internationalen Wettbewerben aufgerieben. Und Chelsea konnte sich Woche für Woche, Montag bis Freitag auf den kommenden Gegner vorbereiten.
Ja, die berühmte Mehrfachbelastung. Wir haben dann so ein weiteres Thema von Brandlhuber, was so ganz leicht auch in diese Richtung geht. Ihnen interessieren die taktischen Anweisungen oder überhaupt Anweisungen vorm Spiel oder in der Halbzeit. Und er nennt da jetzt zwei Beispiele. Er schreibt, beschränkt es sich, wie zum Beispiel bei der französischen Nationalmannschaft, bei der WM mal zu sehen war, auf so Dinge wie, Zitat, näher dran sein, besser in den Zweikampf gehen, auf Spiele XY besser aufpassen. Oder, anderes Beispiel, Guardiola bei All or Nothing. Hier sind die Räume, die müsst ihr bespielen. XY, positioniere dich nicht mehr in diesen Räumen. Weil er schreibt, das französische Beispiel mutet an, wie bei uns in der Kreisliga. Bei Guardiola wundert es ihn tatsächlich, dass das aber dann so reicht. Oder sind die Spieler so gut, dass sich so einfache Anweisungen dann auch schon auszahlen?
Also ja, die Spieler sind so gut, dass du ihnen nur noch ganz wenig mitgeben willst. Da sind wir wieder bei der Komplexität des Werkzeugkastens. Wie viele Bausteine hast du schon zur Verfügung? Aber auch situationsbedingt. Jürgen Klopp zum Beispiel, die haben halt ihr eigenes Analystenteam, das quasi live analysiert, live schneidet. Mit dem Halbzeitpfiff 30 Sekunden später ist alles auf den Monitoren in der Kabine. Und dann kann er den Spielern zeigen, wiederkehrende Fehler, wiederkehrende Räume, was auch immer. Leute, das müssen wir anders machen, das müssen wir anders machen. Selten werden mehr als drei Informationen mitgegeben, weil das Spieler auch nicht mehr unter diesem Stress in der Kürze der Zeit aufnehmen können. Da musst du dich wirklich aufs ganz Wesentliche beschränken, in der Gruppe. Das kann aber tatsächlich dann auch sowas Basic-mäßiges sein wie Jungs aggressiver, wenn es einfach zu lasch ist an dem Tag oder einfach eine ganz klare Ansage wacht mal auf. Die kann mal nett, leise, die kann mal in Nichtzimmer-Lautstärke sein. Bis hin zu hochkomplexen Dingen, wie du es eben bei Guardiola beschrieben hast. Wenn ich jetzt an das Spiel Manchester City gegen Liverpool zurückdenke, das wir live vor Ort produziert haben und da war einfach eine Energie auf dem Feld. Das war auf einem so unfassbar hohen taktischen Niveau, dass du halt wirklich der Kleinigkeit nur ansprechen konntest. Weil es war Rasenschach in relativ hohem Tempo. Und da ist dann eine Halbzeitansprache wirklich sehr speziell.
Es war auch irgendwie Rasenschach mit Boxhandschuhen.
Es war ein Spiel, in dem alles drin war. Da geht es dann wirklich extrem ins Detail. Und wenn City jetzt gegen Fulham spielt und 85% Ballbesitz hat, dann geht es halt um andere Dinge.
Gut, wir haben noch ein paar Fragen bekommen zum Bereich Jugendfußball. Da würde ich jetzt mal so zwei zusammenfassen. Mitmacher hat gefragt, wenn angenommen deine, vielleicht noch zu bekommenden Kinder, wollten mal Profifußballer werden, würde dich das freuen. Daran angeschlossen dann die knallharte Frage von Nurder Markus. Wie sieht denn deiner Meinung nach der Jugendfußball in Deutschland aus, weil er ja unter anderem von so Leuten wie dem ehemaligen HSV-Sportdirektor Berner Peters kritisiert wurde zuletzt?
Zur ersten Frage fällt mir ein Tweet ein, den ich heute Morgen gesehen habe von einem Vater, der sich sehr abfällig darüber geäußert hat. Dass er mit seinem Sohn auf irgendeine Lego-Convention gegangen ist oder einen Lego-Wettbewerb und seinem Sohn dabei zugeguckt hat, wie er Bausteine übereinander gedrückt hat und die dann irgendwas ergeben haben. Und er möchte doch lieber, dass sein Sohn ein Footballer geworden ist. Also, furchtbar, also englisch sprach ich das Ganze. Geisterte heute Morgen in meiner Timeline rum und ich habe nur gedacht, was für ein Arschloch. Ich unterstütze, falls es dazu kommen sollte, meinen Sohn, meine Tochter in dem, was sie gerne, was er gerne tun würde. Und wenn es Fußball ist, dann freut mich das, weil ich vieles aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung mitgeben kann. Und wenn es kein Fußball ist, dann ist das halt so. Ich versuche, ich kann jetzt natürlich nur in der Theorie sprechen. Das ist dann, ich glaube, wenn es soweit ist, ist das dann, kann vieles anders laufen. Aber ich nehme mir fest vor, und auch da spreche ich jetzt erst mal nur für mich, auch wenn ich ziemlich sicher auch da für meine Freundin sprechen kann, wir haben keine unerfüllten Sehnsüchte, die wir auf unser, möglicherweise irgendwann mal Kind projizieren müssen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch der falsche Weg.
Genau, und dann ist das ja quasi so deine persönliche Haltung. Und wie würdest du das System Jugendfußball beurteilen? Ist das was Erstrebenwertes, sein Kind in dieses System zu übergeben?
Man sollte sich dessen bewusst sein, dass man unheimlich viel Aufwand für sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich keinen bis sehr wenig Ertrag fährt. Weil man ist nicht das, oder das Kind wird nicht das Einzige sein, das Fußballprofi werden möchte. Es gibt viele Dinge, die meiner Meinung nach gut und auch viele Dinge, die meiner Meinung nach nicht gut, nicht richtig laufen. Was aber, und das ist für mich das wichtigste, was dir als Elternteil, was dir als Elternpaar bewusst sein sollte, ist, dass du sehr, sehr viel investieren wirst und möglicherweise keinen nennenswerten, keinen zählbaren Ertrag aus der ganzen Geschichte rausziehen wirst, weil einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit unheimlich gering ist. Und du kannst sie auch kaum bis gar nicht steigern. Das liegt wirklich nur an der Entwicklung des Kindes. Du kannst es natürlich ein Stück weit unterstützen, indem du deinem Kind Dinge wie realistische Selbsteinschätzung, eine gewisse Einstellung, eine gewisse Mentalität, einen gewissen Ehrgeiz mitgibst, vorlebst, oder ihm erklärst, worauf es ankommt. Umsetzen muss es am Ende der Sohn oder die Tochter. Aber auch all das ist nur die Grundvoraussetzung für einen sehr, sehr langen Weg.
Und magst du das noch konkretisieren, was du gesagt hast, dass es gute Dinge gibt und auch Dinge, die schlecht laufen?
Also zunächst mal ist die Ausbildung der Spieler und Spielerinnen heutzutage auf einem sehr, sehr hohen Niveau. Weil ich habe ja ganz am Anfang gesagt, dass sich der Jugendfußball auch professionalisiert hat. Gerade mit den NLZs, mit den Anforderungen, dass die Trainer entsprechend lizenziert sein müssen und die Trainingsbedingungen. Das sehr wissenschaftliche Training, die Expertise aus verschiedensten Bereichen, Sportwissenschaftler, Sportpsychologen und auch die weibliche Form. Verzeiht mir, wenn ich das nicht immer mitnenne. All das führt dazu, dass die Kinder sehr früh eine sehr umfassende Ausbildung bekommen. Das ist das, was gut läuft. Was nicht so gut läuft, das lässt sich aber nicht ändern, weil eben durch die Professionalisierung ist, dass es dann halt auch sehr früh sehr hart wird. Sehr hart in den Entscheidungen. Wo wir wieder bei dem Punkt des Drucks der Sportpsychologie wären. Oder ich glaube, das ist dann schon Psychologie im Allgemeinen. Wie gehe ich damit um? Man könnte jetzt auch sagen, ja gut, dann werden sie aber früher aufs Leben vorbereitet. Die Frage ist, muss man einem 16-Jährigen schon quasi seinen Lebenstraum nehmen?
Vor allem geben ja diese Kinder und Jugendlichen sehr, sehr viel dafür auf, was ja eigentlich auch Teil einer Jugend sein sollte.
Die geben unfassbar viel auf. Wir haben neun Spieler bei uns, die zum Beispiel im Internat leben. Die sind 400 und mehr Kilometer von ihren Eltern weg, mit 15. Die haben niemanden, wenn die abends ins Bett gehen, mit dem sie sich mal unterhalten können. Klar, die können per WhatsApp mit ihren Eltern schreiben oder mal per Facetime, damit sie sich mal sehen. Aber die sind halt mehrere hundert Kilometer von zu Hause weg, werden aus dem sozialen Umfeld gerissen.
Die Einschnitte beginnen da schon relativ früh.
Genau, neue Schule und alles nur für einen Traum, den halt vielleicht einer sich erfüllen wird. Also das sind alles Dinge, denen musst du dir bewusst... Und die haben ja auch keine klassische Jugend. Ich weiß nicht, ob die schon mal auf einen Baum geklettert sind. Kennt keiner von denen. Das sind ganz banale Dinge, die uns in unserer Jugend alle geprägt haben. Aber die sind halt von acht bis, oder halb acht, ich weiß gar nicht, wann die Schule mittlerweile beginnt, bis 15.30, 16 Uhr. Und dann kommen sie zum Trainingsplatz, also fahren zurück zum NLZ ins Internat, ziehen sich die Fußballschuhe an, kommen in die Kabine, gehen wieder hoch, machen die Hausaufgaben, legen sich schlafen. Fünf Tage die Woche. Verantwortung, die wir halt haben.
Ich habe hier noch eine Frage von Manuon, die mich persönlich auch sehr interessiert. Er fragt, wie hat sich deinem...
Oder sie, wissen wir nicht.
Oh, stimmt. Er oder sie, tatsächlich. Wie hat sich deinem Einblick nach der Blick auf das Thema Homosexualität im Profifußballumfeld in den letzten fünf Jahren verändert? Wird da in den Umkleidekabinen bei der Trainerausbildung oder generell unter Menschen, die sich im und um den Profifußball herum bewegen, gespürt?
Nein, leider nicht. Mein persönlicher Blick ist da weiterhin unverändert. Ihr kennt meine Einstellung zu dem Thema. Das versuche ich auch vorzuleben. Da gibt es immer wieder auch Möglichkeiten bei den Spielern. Da mache ich in gar keinen großen Vorwurf, dass Kids in dem Alter noch viele Dinge sehr unbedacht äußern. Da ist es dann meine Aufgabe, und da kommen wir zu dem Punkt mit dem Zugang, mich nicht hinzustellen und sagen, was seid ihr eigentlich für Idioten? Das sagen wir nicht, weil so und so, sondern zu sagen, pass mal auf, warum ist dein Mitspieler, der jetzt vielleicht gerade mal Schmerzen hat und sich möglicherweise auch ein bisschen zu sehr anstellt, warum ist er keine Pussy? Naja, verstehe ich nicht. So, und dann suchst du halt das Gespräch, und dann guckt er dich nach zwei Minuten an und sagt, du hast recht. So, da haben wir jetzt halt unheimlich viele Möglichkeiten, den Jungs gewisse Dinge einfach mitzugeben. Aber mein Blick insgesamt ist schon so, dass sich da, meiner Wahrnehmung nach, die Diskussion gibt es weiterhin, aber viel geändert hat sich nicht. Also der Ist-Zustand ist immer noch genauso wie vor fünf Jahren.
Der Zeitraum mit den fünf Jahren ist vielleicht zufällig, vielleicht auch gar nicht zufällig, weil fünf Jahre jetzt das Outing von Thomas Witzesberger zurückliegt. Aber da würde ich jetzt schon gerne nochmal einhaken, dass im Profifußball es da ganz besondere Gegebenheiten gibt und es ja letztlich auch, es liegt nicht an uns, irgendwelchen Leuten zu sagen, wie offen oder nicht offen sie mit ihrer Sexualität umgehen. Das muss jeder für sich entscheiden. Aber du arbeitest jetzt ja in einem Bereich, wo du dich mit Menschen beschäftigst, mit Jugendlichen, die sich ja auch in ihrer Sexualität noch finden, wo das Thema ja ein viel, viel wichtigeres noch ist, weil noch eine größere Unsicherheit herrscht und weil vielleicht auch noch viel mehr Fragen auch aufkommen, die für uns, die wir uns gefunden haben in unserem Erwachsensein, ja schon geklärt haben. Deswegen wundert mich, dass das nicht wenigstens ein bisschen mehr thematisiert wird, weil es später in der Lebensrealität der Jugendlichen eine große Rolle.
Ich habe den Karaoke-Abend im Trainingslager angesprochen mit der Musikrichtung, die dort gehört wurde und was die Jungs halt hören. Mir ist zum Teil, bin ich aus dem Kopfschütteln nicht mehr rausgekommen aus den Lyrics, die in dem einen oder anderen Deutschrap-Song, die einzelnen Textzeilen, was da halt so gesungen wurde. Und ich fange jetzt, es geht jetzt hier nicht um eine Deutschrap-Diskussion, aber da müssen wir natürlich auch aufpassen, beziehungsweise ist dann meine oder unsere Aufgabe. Da werden ja auch Bilder vermittelt. Und ich merke ja auch, dass die Jungs gewisse Lifestyles dann kopieren wollen. Und wenn du immer nur hörst, dass schwul ein Schimpfwort ist oder in einem negativen Kontext genutzt wird und dass Frauen nur für, eigentlich müsste jetzt einen Zensurpiep raushauen, was ich da alles gehört habe. Und das ist nicht Untergrund, sondern das sind gängige Songs. Werden halt Bilder vermittelt, wo ich mich dann auch frage, ist ein 15-Jähriger, schafft er es, das dann in den Kontext zu setzen? Beziehungsweise das als, und das wird ja gerne dann genutzt, er heißt ja Kunst, das als Kunstform anzusehen.
Und das zu abstrahieren vom echten Leben.
Und das zu abstrahieren vom echten Leben. Ich habe festgestellt, dass viele das eben nicht können.
Ja, da wird halt auch ein Ton gesetzt. Also man, das kennt man doch aus jeder anderen Musik- oder Kunstrichtung, wenn wir als Jugendliche irgendwas konsumiert haben, dann hat man das übernommen in seine eigene Sprache, in sein eigenes, wie man sich ausdrückt, was auch immer.
Ja, und das ist tatsächlich eine... Ich werde niemals verbieten, irgendwas zu hören. Aber wir haben dann schon im Trainerteam auch zusammengesessen und haben überlegt, Leute, sprechen wir das mal an? Einfach nur, um da auch einem gewissen pädagogischen Anspruch gerecht zu werden.
Und habt ihr es dann gemacht?
Wir hatten die Sportpsychologin mit am Tisch, die gesagt hat, dass sie es mit auf ihre Agenda setzt, weil das vielleicht ein Thema ist, dass sie eher mit den Jungs besprechen kann.
Ist ja vielleicht auch im Zweigespräch besser aufgehoben als in so einer Gruppensituation.
Vielleicht sind solche Themen tatsächlich besser, wenn es nicht die Trainer machen, sondern halt jemand, der mit der Aufstellung nichts zu tun hat. Aber das sind alles Dinge, da musst du ja mit beachten.
Ja, da finde ich es halt Wahnsinn, welche Verantwortung der Jugendfußball und alle daran beteiligten Personen haben. Und manche sind sich dieser Verantwortung bewusst. Und ich hatte aber auch schon mit Leuten zu tun oder habe von Situationen gehört, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, da täte so ein Bewusstsein sehr gut, weil du eben... Es ist so ein Zwischending, glaube ich. Du behandelst Menschen, die in Teilen ihrer Entwicklung schon sehr erwachsen sind. Und letztlich ist es auch ein erwachsenes Umfeld, nämlich ein leistungs-
und arbeitent- orientiertes Umfeld.
Und gleichzeitig sind es aber ja noch keine Erwachsenen.
Nein, die sind 15, 16, die kommen noch nicht mal in eine Diskothek rein. So, und wir sehen die Hälfte der Spieler häufiger als ihre Eltern.
Interessantes, spannendes Thema. Vielleicht dazu ein letzter, kleiner Schlenker dann eben auch zu, wie man sich in der Öffentlichkeit darstellt. Salva hat gefragt nach dem Interview von Stefan Kretschmer, ohne dass wir jetzt da vielleicht so im Detail drauf eingehen wollen, aber auch bezüglich Erdogan-Öse-Gündoan-Affäre Colin Kaepernick können und sollten Sportlerinnen sich politisch kritisch äußern?
Ja, Punkt.
Und warum tun sie es so selten? Liegt das auch an uns?
Man könnte jetzt das Interview von Kretschmer dazu ziehen, allerdings musst du das differenziert betrachten. In einer Sache gebe ich ihm recht, dass wenn du als Spieler, als Person des öffentlichen Lebens heutzutage äußerst, hast du mit unheimlich vielen Reaktionen und auch mit unheimlich vielen heftigen Reaktionen zu tun. Das Thema hatten wir auch eben bei Ribery und so weiter. Was mich an dem Interview aber elementar stört, ist die Aussage, dass es in Deutschland keine Meinungsfreiheit mehr gibt. Denn mir fehlen konkret Beispiele, was darf man denn nicht mehr sagen, ohne, und deswegen meine ich mit differenziert, ohne von irgendwelchen Sponsoren oder sonst was Repressionen, Vertragskündigungen, was auch immer alles angeführt hat, befürchten zu müssen. Also wirklich konkrete Beispiele. Ich habe gehört, Colin Kaepernick hat das Interview auch gelesen. Ich habe auch gehört, dass er seitdem aus dem Lachen nicht mehr rauskommt. Also ich könnte mich jetzt aufregen, aber ich habe beschlossen, mich nicht darüber aufzuregen. Denn wenn du das einfach in einen Kontext setzt und dir viele seiner Aussagen aus der Vergangenheit anschaust und durchliest, dann sind alle Aussagen für mich sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Zur Ausgangsfrage, ich bleibe dabei, sie sollten sich weiter frei äußern, dann kommen aber auch Dinge zum Tragen, die du vielleicht so von einigen nicht erwartest. Ist die Frage, wollen wir das?
Ja, ich meine, man kann ja niemanden dazu zwingen, eine politische Haltung zu haben und sie dann auch zu vertreten.
Jeder hat eine.
Jeder Mensch hat wahrscheinlich auch die, die es nicht von sich wissen. Aber welche Rolle spielen denn da Profifußballer als Identifikationsfiguren und Multiplikatoren? Ich habe mich dazu auch mal geäußert, selber bei Twitter, das ist dann viral gegangen, das war dann vielleicht auch gar nicht so toll.
War so ein Internetstar?
Nein, nein, anscheinend hat es einen Zeitgeist getroffen, aber den wollte ich damit eigentlich gar nicht treffen. Aber rund um die Hashtag Wir sind mehr, um das Benefizkonzert in Chemnitz, nicht Benefiz, falscher Ausdruck, aber die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen, auf was ich mich beziehe. Da ist mir einfach nur aufgefallen, dass es bestimmte Gruppen von Leuten mit großer Reichweite gab, die sich dazu nicht geäußert haben. Und dazu haben fast ausnahmslos alle Fußballer, Profifußballer gehört, denen ich so gefolgt bin auf meinem Kanal. Das fand ich einfach erwähnenswert und habe das dann auch kritisch hinterfragt. Jetzt ist aber die Frage, kann jemand wie ich überhaupt erwarten von jemandem, dass er eine politische Haltung hat? Ich kam eben so ein bisschen aus dieser Vorbildnummer, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ihr erreicht so viele, vor allem auch junge Menschen, dass ihr, das ist schon, wenn ihr eine Position habtet, ist dann schon auch mal gut, die dann mal zu äußern.
Die Frage ist, haben sie die Position, die du auch hast?
Ja, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Das ist das, was ich meine, wenn du es jetzt wirklich, sag mal, per Gesetz jeden dazu zwingst, dann kommen vielleicht auch Dinge raus, die du halt so nicht erwartet hast. Damit müsste ich aber auch leben. Ich persönlich würde mich auch freuen, wenn viele Leute mit großer Reichweite sich frei äußern. Hat aber die logische Konsequenz und deswegen ist diese Frage, kann ich das auch erwarten, von jemandem, der nicht in der Situation ist, diese Reichweite zu haben, schwierig zu beantworten, weil die Reaktionen werden schon sehr heftig sein. Gerade, wenn es um so politische Themen wie den Hashtag wir sind mehr und so weiter sind. Und die Reaktionen, die kommen immer aus derselben Ecke. Die heftigen Reaktionen, die gegenreden. Willst du jetzt jedes Mal in dieses Westnetz stoßen? Oder willst du jedes Mal die gute Sache unterstützen? Das geht ja quasi einher. Also die in deinen Augen gute Sache. Auch in meinen Augen gute Sache. Um es mal sachlich zu beschreiben. Ich bleibe dabei, dass du keinen zwingen kannst. Ich kann auch jeden verstehen, der sagt, ich habe darauf keinen Bock. Ich finde das zwar eigentlich toll, aber ich habe keine Lust, das über meine sozialen Accounts zu fördern, weil das ist mir der Stress einfach nicht wert. Ist auch okay, musst du so hinnehmen. Ich würde mich aber über jeden freuen, der sagt, das ist in meinen Augen eine gute Sache. Völlig egal was, wir gehen jetzt mal ein bisschen weg von dem Hashtag, das ist in meinen Augen eine gute Sache. Das unterstütze ich jetzt.
Ich glaube, es geht auch gar nicht so sehr um das jedes Mal. Und ich gebe dir da auch völlig recht, und ich habe da genauso viel Verständnis für jemanden, der sich nicht äußert, eben weil er die Sturmflut, die dann da auf ihn zukommt, vermeiden möchte. Ich glaube, worauf sich Max Tweed damals bezog, und so ging es ja mir auch ein Stück weit, dass man halt, obwohl dann gerade insgesamt so eine gewisse Welle aufkam, bei diesem Hashtag, um den es jetzt geht, rund um diese Veranstaltungen Chemnitz, dass da so aus der Fußball-Ecke jegliche in der Wahrnehmung, so war meine Wahrnehmung auch, vielleicht gab es Äußerungen, die wir einfach nicht mitbekommen haben, aber jegliche Unterstützung gefehlt hat, wo man sich eigentlich denkt, Mensch, da sind durchaus viele...
Oder eine Positionierung. Wir leben doch gerade Zeiten, in denen es vielleicht nicht mehr reicht, die Klappe zu halten, sondern in denen es vielleicht wirklich mal angemessen wäre, sich zu positionieren, auch wenn das wehtut. Ich kriege ja auch immer wieder Mails von Leuten, die mir sagen, halt deine verdammte linksversiffte Haltung aus dem Rasenfunk raus. Da habe ich auch schon viele Diskussionen geführt. Dann sage ich, nee, sehe ich einfach gerade nicht. Das ist jetzt gerade eine Zeit, da kann man nicht mehr sagen, wir trennen jetzt die Politik aus allen Lebensbereichen raus. Jetzt ist die Zeit, wo du dich mal hinstellen musst und sagen musst, Leute, ich stehe für diese Werte. Wenn ihr nicht dafür steht, dann kann ich mich mit euch nicht identifizieren und ich finde das nicht gut.
Und da würde man sich natürlich wünschen, dass Menschen, die eine Vorbildfunktion haben, die einen Zugang zu jungen Menschen haben, einfach sich positionieren oder einfach halt aber klarmachen, es ist kein Fehler, politisch zu sein.
Würde ich mir auch freuen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich haben wir da auch drei Stühle eine mal hingekriegt.
Lösen werden wir das auch nicht können. Ich halte das Thema tatsächlich weitestgehend, aber jetzt bei uns in der Jugend raus. Bis zu dem Punkt, wenn es gewisse Dinge gibt, oder wir hatten mal einen Vortrag, bei dem habe ich aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung erzählt, aber es ist nicht so, dass ich jeden Tag da stehe und denen irgendwas erzähle. Aber ich muss tatsächlich auch sagen, dass die Kids dann einen ganz anderen Umgang und einen ganz anderen Zugang zu haben. Stand jetzt habe ich gar nicht das Gefühl, dass die sich groß damit beschäftigen. Die leben halt in dem Bereich vor sich hin.
Ja, die mehr von der politischsten Generation, die es jemals gegeben habe.
Vielleicht sind die, wenn die Anfang 20 sind, das weiß ich nicht. Aber jetzt so gerade in dem Alter tatsächlich.
Da sind ja auch die Menschen verschieden. Vielleicht kommen wir noch zu einem abschließenden Themenkomplex, wo es eben auch viele Fragen zu gab. Wir haben jetzt viel über deine Trainer-Tätigkeit gesprochen. Die Kommentatoren, Experten, wie auch immer sie mögen, Tätigkeit haben wir ein bisschen ausgespart. Da hat aber unter anderem Jay Touchdown die interessante Frage gestellt, welche neuen Einblicke über das Fußballgeschäft gewinnt man denn durch so eine Tätigkeit? Und hat sich dadurch dein Blick auf den Fußball verändert?
Na, die Frage habe ich ja schon eben so halbwegs beantwortet, als ich gesagt habe, für mich hat es sich gar nicht so sehr verändert, bis auf den Schreibkram. Aber ich habe ja schon als Spieler tatsächlich versucht, immer auch zu verstehen, was der Trainer jetzt vorhat. Versucht, wie er zu denken, einfach um die Komplexität des Ganzen zu sehen.
Bei der Kommentatoren-Tätigkeit, wo du quasi zum ersten Mal in der Rolle bist, dass du das bewertest, was live auf dem Platz passiert.
Es ist eine sehr spannende Wahrnehmung, wie die andere Seite das halt sieht. Wie werden Interviews vor dem Spiel wahrgenommen? Wie werden Aussagen interpretiert? Ich finde das immer sehr, sehr spannend in der Vorbereitung auf ein Spiel, wenn wir dann in der Redaktion oder im Regierraum zusammensitzen und der Leiter der Sendung mit Moderator und meiner Wenigkeit und Kommentator, und dann sitzen wir zusammen und dann... Ah, okay, das war jetzt die Aussage, welche nehmen wir für den Vorlauf und warum. Also, sehr spannend, wie die das sehen. Und ansonsten, was war der zweite Teil der Frage? Dazu wollte ich tatsächlich noch was sagen. Hab ich jetzt aber wieder vergessen.
Ob du neue Einblicke gewonnen hast, das war... eigentlich war das die Frage. Ich hab's eben noch so ein bisschen erweitert, um den Punkt, wie eben jetzt das journalistische Bewerten von Leistungen auf den Platz...
Ach so, ja, was ich grundsätzlich versuche, ich bewerte und analysiere Szenen und Leistungen so, wie ich es auch als Spieler akzeptieren würde. Das heißt, ich versuche, mich nicht hinzustellen und zu erklären und zu erzählen, ja, da muss er einfach nur, weil ja, das ist immer sehr leicht gesagt, weil wenn du in der Situation bist, hast du eine andere Wahrnehmung als jemand, der die Vogelperspektive hat und einen tollen Überblick über das ganze Spielfeld hat. Und ich versuche, immer auch die Sicht des Spielers zu erklären. Warum hat er das denn jetzt so gemacht?
Aber mal was anderes. Kann es sein, dass wenn Kommentatoren so was sagen wie, da muss er einfach nur, dass sie damit im Grunde ja nichts anderes tun, als die Sicht des Fans aufgreifen? Weil sitzt nicht der Fan am Stammtisch, ich sage es jetzt mal ganz salopp, und sagt genau das, also projiziert seine eigene sehr oberflächliche Meinung auf das.
Oftmals hast du ja mit der Aussage sogar recht. Wenn er jetzt einfach nur drei Meter weiter links steht, dann hat er den. Das ist ja häufig so leicht von außen. Nur ich versuche dann halt die Perspektive entweder des Spielers oder des Schiedsrichters zu erklären. Wie ist die Wahrnehmung, wenn du da stehst? Wenn du im 16er als Spieler da stehst, hast du hier rechts neben dir deinen Stürmer und guckst gleichzeitig auf den Ball, ist dein Blickfeld extrem beschränkt. Das weiß ich noch, wenn du in der Aktion bist, ist dein Blickfeld, das sind maximal fünf Meter in der Breite, die deine Augen abdecken. Wenn wir auf der Tribüne sitzen oder mit der Führungskamera, haben wir nahezu das ganze oder das halbe Spielfeld und einen tollen Überblick und keinen Druck. Aber du selber hast auf dem Feld ganz andere Einflüsse, eine ganz andere Wahrnehmung. Und das versuche ich in meiner Analyse rüberzubringen, einfach um diesen Transfer zu schaffen, das nicht immer alles so leicht ist, wie es vielleicht aussieht. Und das gilt halt auch für Schiedsrichter. Deswegen versuche ich in der Analyse von Schiedsrichterentscheidungen auch immer die perspektive, die wortwörtliche Perspektive des Schiedsrichters zu erläutern, was der jetzt in dem Moment sieht. Weil ein Zweikampf, ob du ihn von hinten oder von vorne siehst, sind oftmals zwei Paar Schuhe.
Verstehst du jetzt gewisse Mechanismen dann auch besser, wie es so in der Fußballberichterstattung abläuft? Du hast ja das schon mit dem Anspringen auf gewisse Zitate, das hast du ja schon...
Ja gut, das ist jetzt vielleicht keine Herangehensweise, wie sie alle umsetzen wollen oder wie sie alle haben. Insofern gibt es da halt auch große Unterschiede. Ich bekomme jetzt noch mehr ein Gespür dafür. Oder ich spüre die Unterschiede deutlicher. Zwischen kommentieren, beschreiben, analysieren. Ist es wichtiger, wie der Gärtner des Nachbarn heißt? Oder wie passiert ist?
Und dann siehst du deine Rolle so als das Einordnende?
Genau, ich sehe meine Rolle als der Transfer der Perspektive vom Platz für den Zuschauer, damit er viele Dinge einfach anders versteht.
Glaubst du, wenn du jetzt noch mal Spieler wärst und wir würden dich interviewen, glaubst du, du würdest vor allem auch im Kontext nach Spielen andere Antworten geben, als du es als Spieler getan hast?
Das glaube ich nicht. Nee, da war ich auch als Spieler relativ frei und auch unabhängig davon. Ich wurde halt meistens geschickt, wenn wir verloren haben und kein anderer wollte, dann komm Ralf, du kriegst das hin. Insofern, ich glaube, da wäre ich genauso ich wie sonst auch.
Und wie siehst du den ganzen Bereich des Fußballschonendismus, mit dem du jetzt ja nochmal auf einer anderen Art und Weise zu tun hast? Ich meine, da gibt es halt die unterschiedlichsten Ansätze und manche Leute sehen es kritischer, andere sehen es besser. Dann gibt es so Do-it-yourself-Typen wie wir, die dann manchmal auch von sich behaupten, sie würden es vielleicht besser oder anders machen, was ja auch erstmal fraglich wäre. Aber grundsätzlich gibt es ja ganz viele Leute, die über Fußball sprechen und vielleicht gar nicht immer so viel wissen. Da schließe ich mich jetzt zum Beispiel auch explizit mit ein. Die Schlusskonferenzen mit dir haben immer eine andere Farbung gehabt als die mit anderen Gästen.
Also ganz grundsätzlich ist Fußball und Fußballjournalismus und Fußballberichterstattung zu 80 Prozent sprechen darüber, was gar nicht passiert ist oder was noch passieren wird.
Also meinst du sowas wie Transfers und Gerüchte oder?
Und Diskussionen, was wäre wenn und so weiter. Denn ansonsten würden wir von reiner Analyse sprechen. Ich finde es gut, dass es eine ganz, ganz große Vielfalt in der Art und Weise gibt. Podcast, Videopodcast, Print, Online-Analyse, Spielverlagerung. Was weiß ich, was es da alles gibt. Die alle unterschiedliche Aspekte eines Fußballspiels beleuchten. Spielverlagerung zum Beispiel. Für jeden Taktikinteressierten kann ich absolut nur empfehlen. Aber auch das ist nicht die einzige Wahrheit eines Fußballspiels. Nur als Beispiel, also ich schätze die Jungs und Mädels wirklich sehr, weil das extrem fundiert ist, das geht extrem in die Tiefe, extrem detailliert. Aber nehmen wir jetzt das Champions League-Finale. Real Madrid gegen Liverpool. Da kannst du dich tot analysieren. Die haben mit diametral abkippender Viererkette gespielt. Wenn der Torhüter zweimal daneben greift, kannst du auch mit frontal abkippendem Achter spielen, nutzt nichts. Nur um aufzuzeigen, auch das ist nicht die eine Wahrheit, aber nicht die einzige auf diesem Planeten. Die Rangehensweise eines Fans, die haben nicht genug Gras gefressen, sind nicht genug gelaufen und hätten enger Mann sein müssen, ist möglicherweise auch die Wahrheit, aber auch nicht die einzige. Weil vielleicht der Innenverteidiger tatsächlich viel zu weit außen stand und immer wieder die Schnittstelle zwischen IV und AV offengelassen hat und der Gegner das erkannt hat, genutzt hat, Pass, Rückpass, Tor. Find ich toll, dass es das alles gibt. Hat sehr häufig auch eine enorm hohe Qualität auf seine eigene Art und Weise. Das trifft auf die Schlusskonferenz zu, ob 390 über seinen Verein spricht und was es noch alles gibt, um auch ein bisschen... Oder den Milan Thun, der auch einen ganz anderen Blick auf den Fußball hat, den St. Pauli spielt. Und genauso wie es da viel Qualität und wenig Qualität gibt, gilt das auch für die, ich sag mal, renommierten Journalisten, die das hauptberuflich machen und ihre Spielberichte schreiben und ihre Analysen. Da muss jeder aber für sich das rausziehen, wie er ein Spiel gerne betrachtet und analysiert haben möchte. Und es gibt zum Beispiel die Taktik-Nerds, und das meine ich null abwertend, ganz im Gegenteil, die sich liebend gerne einen Artikel durchlesen, der selbst für mich als halbwegs lizenzierter Trainer und ehemaligen Fußballprofi fast schon zu weit gehen. Aber wenn es den Leuten Spaß macht und einen Mehrwert bietet und sie dadurch ein Spiel besser verstehen können, sehr gerne. Ich möchte nur immer, und das gilt für alle, keiner von uns hat die absolute Wahrheit. Es gibt immer ganz viele Facetten eines Spiels. Das beste Beispiel hatten wir gestern im Football. Und da habe ich gestern zum Beispiel auch viele Rückmeldungen bekommen. Ein kurzer Ausflug wegen der Schiedsrichteranscheidung.
Jetzt geht es um das Spiel zwischen den Saints und den Rams, wo es nicht den Pass-Interference-Koll gab.
Ich bin kein Football-Experte, aber wenn ich mir halbwegs die Definition von Pass-Interference durchlese, könnte man meinen, dass das hinkommt. Eine Stunde vorher, im dritten Viertel, habe ich einen Tweet abgesetzt, wo ich geschrieben habe, eigentlich haben die Saints es sich selbst zuzuschreiben, dass es hier noch so spannend ist, weil sie gerade in der ersten Hälfte, die deutlich bessere Mannschaft waren, haben wirklich viele Punkte liegen lassen. Mindestens zwei Touchdowns quasi nur noch mit Fieldgold gerettet. Und dann habe ich diesen Tweet aufgegriffen und habe nur den Kommentar dazu geschrieben, inklusive dem Nicht-Fif. Also inklusive dem Nicht-Fif oder der Nicht-Fif hat auch irgendwie so etwas dafür gesorgt, dass sie das Spiel jetzt verloren haben.
Genau, da muss man jetzt ganz kurz einordnen für alle die, die das eben nicht mitbekommen haben. Die New Orleans Saints, es ging um den Einzug im Superbowl. Es war kurz vor Ende des Spiels. Sie hätten durch diese Strafe die Möglichkeit gehabt, sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie zum Touchdown kommen oder zumindest zu Punkten. Und dieser Call wurde nicht gemacht. Das heißt, das war wie so ein nicht gegebener Elfmeter in der 89. Minute. Und dazu gehört, es ging dann in die Verlängerung. Und das hat dann der Gegner eben dann gewonnen.
Genau, aber natürlich hat das einen sehr entscheidenden Einfluss auf das Spiel gehabt, um jetzt die Brücke wieder zu kriegen. Die einzige Wahrheit. Aber in der Analyse wird man sicherlich auch dann zu dem Schluss kommen. Leute, wenn wir vorher nur die Hälfte unserer Chancen genutzt hätten, das ist halt so. Bitter, weiß ich.
Habt man ja dann auch im zweiten Spiel gesehen, wenn die Chiefs bei der dritten Interception, beim dritten getippten Pass von Tom Brady, wenn da nicht einer über der Line of Scrimmage drüber steht und so dermaßen die Neutral Zone infractured ist.
Das sind halt so verschiedene Dinge, die für mich dann die Geschichte eines Spiels ausmachen und die alle aber auch beleuchtet gehören. Und nicht nur, weil in den ganz seltensten Fällen ist es wirklich so klar, dass es nur diese eine Situation ist. Und ich kann aber auch wiederum jeden verstehen, der sich über die Schiedsrichterentscheidung und das als das Hauptschuldige und nur deswegen. Das ist auch okay.
Ja, und du hast natürlich auch nicht immer den Platz, alle Aspekte zu beleuchten. Also den Platz haben ja nicht mal wir hier in einem Podcast. Wir müssen auch immer Dinge weglassen. Und das kommt halt noch so als zweiter Punkt schon mit dazu. Wir sprechen hier jetzt nicht über Atomphysik oder über Umweltpolitik. Wir sprechen hier über eine Unterhaltungsindustrie. Und da ist es schon auch ein legitimer Ansatz zu sagen, erstes und vielleicht auch einziges Ziel des Fußballs ist es, Menschen zu unterhalten. Wir verhandeln hier nicht die Lösung des Welthungers. Deswegen kann es auch auch legitim sein, das entsprechend zu behandeln.
Ja, ja. Aber geh bitte zu keinem Profifußballer und sag, du bist nur zur Unterhaltung da. Ja, und was halt noch ein großer Unterschied ist... Aber so ist es ja letztlich.
Und das merkt man auch unter Fußballberichterstattung ganz eindeutig. Das ist ein Teil der Unterhaltungsindustrie. Deswegen müssen ja Dramen aufgebaut werden.
Genau, aber genau das ist ja der Grund, warum... Und man kann das ja durchaus wunderbar auf den Rasenfunk projizieren, weil im Grunde unterhalten wir ja auch nur die Menschen, die sich halt auf diesem Niveau für den Fußball interessieren. Und viele andere, die wollen das vielleicht gar nicht und sind zufrieden mit einer anderen Form der Unterhaltung.
Und was die Leute dann auch häufig vergessen, wir sind nicht in der Mathematik, wo zwei plus zwei immer vier ergibt. Im Fußball gibt es ganz wenig richtig und falsch. Es gibt, das ist mein Ansatz, das ist mein Ansatz.
Aber es gibt trotzdem immer einfache Erklärungen. Die mögen nicht immer richtig sein, aber es gibt für jede Geschmacksrichtung eine andere Komplexität der Erklärung für, warum das Spiel jetzt so gelaufen ist.
Ja, aber ich möchte halt darauf hinaus, wenn sich ein Mathematiker hinstellt und sagt, zwei plus zwei sind vier, das ist die absolute Wahrheit. Da werden wir jetzt relativ wenig dran deuten. Du wirst mir keine Argumente liefern können. Du kannst jetzt eine These im Fußball hinstellen und mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit werde ich zumindest eine sinnvolle Gegenthese aufstellen können. Welch, ob die jetzt für dich Sinn ergibt, ist was völlig anderes. Aber sie ist sicherlich auch möglich.
Das stimmt. Und das macht ja auch den Fußball so wunderbar. Deswegen kann man so gut drüber reden. Vielleicht ist dann die letzte Frage dazu der perfekte Abschluss. Drei Fensterhaus hat einen ganzen Fragebogen zu sagen, den du beantworten sollst. Ich picke aber jetzt nur einen Punkt heraus, weil er sich jetzt ganz gut an diese Diskussion anschließt. Welches Sportmagazin liest du am liebsten, Ralph? Und er hat jetzt folgende Optionen. Kicker, Freunde, Sportbild, Sokrates, Panini-Heftchen, wann kommt endlich das Rasenfunkmagazin? Lass mal weg und Etienne Gardet.
Ach so, die Geschichte. Mit Etienne kann ich immer sehr trefflich streiten und diskutieren in unserer Bundesliga-WhatsApp-Gruppe. Ernste Antwort auf die Frage. Und ihr werdet jetzt, viele werden es mir wahrscheinlich nicht glauben, ich habe in den letzten zehn Jahren sechs Pfund für Sportpresse bezahlt. Das waren die sechs Pfund, die ich vor meinem Rückflug jetzt aus London für die Tageszeitung ausgegeben habe. Ich weiß nicht, wann ich mir das letzte Mal einen Magazin gekauft habe. Das liegt aber nicht daran, weil die mir alle irgendwelche kostenlosen Abos zu schicken, sondern das liegt einfach daran, dass ich kein klassischer Leser bin, an dem irgendein Verlagshaus reich wird. Ich habe mir in den letzten Jahren ein Informationsnetzwerk aufgebaut. Sehr sehr viel über Twitter. Aber da auch nicht spezialisiert, dass ich sage, nur ein Link von der Süddeutschen oder nur ein Link vom Kicker oder nur ein Link von 11Freunde, sondern die Pluralität macht es halt einfach aus. Ich folge auch bis auf 11Freunde keinem konkreten Magazin. Sondern vielen Journalisten, die in unterschiedlichsten Häusern arbeiten, bekomme über Retweets unheimlich viel auch reingespült. Und habe darüber hinaus so meine zwei, drei Quellen, wenn ich dann jetzt aktuell hauptsächlich die Premier League kommentiere, in der Vorbereitung. Das ist die BBC Sports macht zum Beispiel. Also da kann man sich unheimlich viele Infos rausziehen in der Vorberichterstattung über deren Homepage und Folge auch dem Twitter-Account. Insofern ist die Frage bei mir tatsächlich sehr falsch aufgehoben.
Okay. Aber es sind ja vielleicht auch einfach unterschiedliche Medien-Nutzungsweiten. Und Etienne Gardet, um das kurz aufzulösen, ist einer von den Rocket Beans, den du bei Bundesliga mit dem du trefflich streiten kannst.
Genau.
Ein Eintracht Frankfurt Fan. Grüße an dieser Stelle sollte er es hören. Ich glaube, damit können wir so langsam hier den Laden dicht machen.
Die Leute werden enttäuscht sein, dass es keine sieben Stunden sind.
Ja, das ist ja aber auch so der Running Gag. Und ich möchte auch da nicht immer denjenigen Futter für bieten, die genau das am Rasenfunk kritisieren. Schaut mal, wir schaffen es auch in knapp unter drei Stunden.
Unglaublich.
Ja, siehst du mal, das ging nämlich tatsächlich schnell vorbei. Ralph, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne.
Wir wünschen dir weiter viel Erfolg bei allem, was du so machst. Ich bin gespannt, was du dann irgendwann mal vom Fußballlehrer erzählst. On- oder Off-Air, da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt. Da habe ich viele Fragen zu. Bei Twitter kann man dir folgen als Ed Felgenreile. Danke, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Gerne. Danke Frank, dass du hierher gekommen bist. Endlich hatten wir dich mal wieder im Rasenfunk. Wunderbar. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, auch herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Tribünengespräch Nummer 28. Hört auch in die anderen Tribünengespräche rein. Unter anderem das angesprochene mit Ralph. Das war die Nummer 12. In der Nummer 11 war er auch schon zu Gast. Da ging es um seine Tätigkeit bei DAZN. Und der Fußballtrainer-Aspekt ist vielleicht auch ganz interessant für euch. All diese Tribünengespräche sind zu finden auf rasenfunk.de. Bis bald mal wieder, macht's gut, ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.